Hello and welcome to your second drink of Golden Ticket.
This is a really great breakdown because it includes a long interview with Rayne Wilson,
and it's not just about this episode, but it was also just about how he got his role as Dwight
and his time playing Dwight on The Office in general.
I mean, so fun to hear all of that from him.
And we've been asking you to write us with your favorite moments from these episodes over in our second drinks folder on OfficeLadies.com.
Mom, this week's winter, we need a sting.
We need a winter sting.
你好，欢迎收听第二杯《金奖券》。这一集解析非常棒，因为它包含了一段与雷恩·威尔森的长篇访谈，内容不仅限于这一集，还谈到了他是如何获得德怀特这个角色，以及他在《办公室》中饰演德怀特的整体经历。我是说，能从他那里听到这些真是太有趣了。我们一直请大家在 OfficeLadies.com 的“第二杯”文件夹里写下你们在这些剧集里最喜欢的瞬间。妈妈，这周的赢家，我们需要一个音效。我们需要一个赢家音效。
Oh.
This week's winter, bobe, bebe, be you.
Is a moment between Michael and Daryl.
Kate M from Providence, Rhode Island, Lauren P. from Kansas City, Missouri, wrote in, and they said,
Hi, hi, office ladies.
One of our favorite scenes in this episode is when Michael walks up to Daryl and says,
Hey, you idiot.
And Daryl says, start over.
哦。这周的赢家，宝贝，宝贝，是你。是迈克尔和达里尔之间的一个瞬间。来自罗德岛州普罗维登斯的凯特·M，来自密苏里州堪萨斯城的劳伦·P 写信来说，嗨，嗨，办公室女士们。我们在这一集里最喜欢的场景之一是迈克尔走到达里尔面前说：“嘿，你这个白痴。”然后达里尔说：“重来。”
And Michael says, sir, I absolutely love that.
moment it makes me laugh every single time I watch it I often find myself saying sir
exactly as Michael says it Steve performed that perfectly you know what why don't we
hear it hey hey hey you idiot start over sir it is such perfect comic timing I know
well we also got a letter from Robin Y in Redmond Oregon who said backstory
I used to work as a bridal consultant.
I helped brides find their wedding dresses
and helped them through everything having to do with the dress.
迈克尔说：“先生。”我绝对喜欢那个瞬间，每次看它我都会笑出声。我经常发现自己像迈克尔说的那样说“先生”。史蒂夫表演得太完美了。你知道吗，为什么我们不听听看呢？嘿，嘿，嘿，你这个白痴。重来。先生。这真是完美的喜剧时机。我知道。嗯，我们还收到了一封来自俄勒冈州雷德蒙德的罗宾·Y 的信，她说背景故事：我曾经是一名婚纱顾问。我帮助新娘找到她们的婚纱，并帮助她们处理与婚纱有关的一切事情。
I got very used to lots of happy emotions
and not so happy emotions.
So one day I was in between appointments
and at the front desk when one of the brides I had helped
came storming into the shop with her dress in the bag.
More backstory, this bride was legendary at the shop
for taking up two appointment time slots
because she refused to take a dress off
我非常习惯于各种快乐的情绪和不那么快乐的情绪。所以有一天，我在预约空档时在前台，这时我帮助过的一位新娘带着她的婚纱袋冲进了店里。更多背景故事，这位新娘在店里很有名，因为她总是占用两个预约时段，因为她拒绝脱下婚纱，
because she was crying, so I knew exactly who she was.
Oh, gosh.
So she storms in, throws her dress on the counter, and says to me, you idiot.
And without hesitation, I said, start over.
Only after figuring out what the problem was, and after she left, did I realize that it was exactly
like what happened between Michael and Daryl in the Golden Ticket episode.
Since then, I've dealt with all sorts of people in weddings and all sorts of emotions
and I can say without a doubt that the best way to respond to someone in that situation is the way Daryl responds to Michael in Golden Ticket.
因为她在哭，所以我完全知道她是谁。哦，天哪。所以她冲进来，把婚纱扔在柜台上，对我说了句：“你这个白痴。”我毫不犹豫地说：“重来。”只有在弄清楚问题出在哪里，并且她离开后，我才意识到这和《金奖券》那一集中迈克尔和达里尔之间发生的事情一模一样。从那以后，我处理过各种各样的新娘和各种各样的情绪，我可以毫无疑问地说，在这种情况下回应某人的最好方式就是达里尔在《金奖券》中回应迈克尔的方式。
If you work in customer service, absolutely channel the calmness of Daryl.
That's such a great story.
Start over.
I wish I could remember that in the moment.
Me too.
You know?
I always think of those things after the fact.
如果你从事客户服务工作，一定要展现出达里尔的冷静。那真是个很棒的故事。重来。重来。我真希望当时能记住这一点。我也是。你知道吗？我总是在事后才想到这些。
I know.
Okay.
So the reason Michael is confronting Daryl is because Michael hid five guys.
golden tickets into boxes of paper, and he's mad that one company found all the tickets.
We got this letter from Julia S. in San Jose, California.
Julia says, I am currently watching Golden Ticket, and something is bothering me.
The whole plot of Golden Ticket is that one company gets all of the tickets, but each of the
tickets were in separate boxes.
我知道。好吧。迈克尔之所以要和达里尔对质，是因为迈克尔把五张金奖券藏进了纸箱里，他很生气有一家公司找到了所有的奖券。我们收到了来自加利福尼亚州圣何塞的朱莉娅·S 的来信。朱莉娅说，我目前正在看《金奖券》，有些事情让我很困扰。《金奖券》的整个情节是有一家公司拿到了所有的奖券，但每张奖券都在不同的盒子里。
How would Blue Cross have seen all of the Golden Tickets at once?
Do they open each one when they arrive for quality check?
I feel like they would stack the boxes in a supply closet and open them when needed.
I'm just wondering, is it realistic for Blue Cross to have found all of the golden tickets all at once?
Okay, I thought about this.
And here's what I think happened.
He wasn't putting the golden tickets into actual reams of paper, right?
It was just in the box.
蓝十字公司怎么可能同时看到所有的金奖券？他们是在收到货进行质量检查时打开每一个盒子吗？我觉得他们会把盒子堆在供应室里，需要的时候才打开。我只是想知道，蓝十字公司一次性找到所有的金奖券现实吗？好吧，我想过这个问题。这就是我认为发生的事情。他不是把金奖券放进真正的纸令里，对吧？它只是在盒子里。
So I could realistically believe that each of these boxes
was going to maybe different departments, and that department was unloading that box and putting them
into a cabinet. That's what I do. When I get my box of paper at home, I take the box, I open it,
and I put all the reams of paper in my, you know, printer cabinet. At first, I was like,
you're right. That's totally implausible. But then I kind of like followed my train of thought.
I'm like, no, I could see it. So basically, your theory is, for example, like an accounting department and human
resources and IT and sales all got their box of paper and they all opened them on the same day.
They all needed paper at the exact same time.
所以我可以现实地相信，这些盒子中的每一个可能都去了不同的部门，而那个部门正在卸下那个盒子并把它们放进柜子里。这就是我所做的。当我在家收到一箱纸时，我拿出盒子，打开它，然后把所有的纸令放进我的，你知道，打印机柜里。起初，我想，你是对的。这完全不可信。但后来我顺着我的思路想了想。我想，不，我能理解。所以基本上，你的理论是，例如，会计部门、人力资源部、IT部和销售部都收到了他们的纸箱，而且他们都在同一天打开了它们。他们都在同一时间需要纸。
I'm not even saying they needed paper.
I am saying that they put it away.
They put it away.
So yes, I guess I'm saying that five different departments received a box and all five
of those departments were very efficient and putting away their paper immediately.
Yes.
我甚至没说他们需要纸。我是说他们把它们收起来了。他们把它们收起来了。他们把它们收起来了。所以是的，我想我是说五个不同的部门收到了一个盒子，而且这五个部门都非常高效，立即把纸收好了。是的。是的。
Well, I might call bullshit on it.
But I'm also just here for the story because I love this episode.
You know, it's almost a bullshit card.
It's like bullshit card adjacent, I think.
Okay.
Well, lady, we got a mom detective's case in our mailbag about this episode.
It's from Dene M from Cherry Hill, New Jersey.
And here's the mystery.
嗯，我可能会说这是胡扯。但我在这里只是为了故事，因为我喜欢这一集。你知道，这几乎是一张胡扯卡。我想这和胡扯卡差不多。好吧，女士，我们的邮件袋里有一个关于这一集的妈妈侦探案件。它来自新泽西州切里希尔的丹·M。这就是谜团。
It's called Whose Leg Is It?
I'm in already.
Okay.
I love it.
Dene says, this is one of my favorite episodes.
I watch it over and over again and noticed that in the superfan episode,
Kevin, Pam, Jim, and Andy are sitting in the break room, and there is a leg between Kevin and Pam.
It looks like there's a person there, but we never see their face.
它叫“那是谁的腿？”我已经入戏了。好的。我喜欢。丹说，这是我最喜欢的剧集之一。我一遍又一遍地看，注意到在超级粉丝版中，凯文、帕姆、吉姆和安迪坐在休息室里，凯文和帕姆之间有一条腿。看起来那里有个人，但我们从未看到他们的脸。
Who is that?
Whose leg is it?
Was there a deleted scene with someone else in the break room with them?
It has been bugging me all of these years.
Do you know the answer to the same?
mystery. I love your show and appreciate all of the hard work you put into making shows and content
for office fans. Thank you. Well, Dene, I'm excited to report this was a very easy case. We're solving
那是谁？那是谁？那是谁的腿？休息室里还有别人吗？有没有被删减的场景？这些年来这一直困扰着我。你知道这个谜团的答案吗？我喜欢你们的节目，感谢你们为办公室粉丝制作节目和内容所付出的所有辛勤工作。谢谢。嗯，丹，我很高兴地报告这是一个非常简单的案件。我们正在解决
this one. We are. And are you ready for this? At 25 minutes and 43 seconds. I saw the leg.
I saw the leg. And after doing a little mom detective work, we realized it is our camera operator
sitting on a stool, they would often do that. They would have this little stool. You know, we've talked about it.
Well, our walls didn't move, so they'd have to, like, sit in the corner. Yeah, they'd have to wedge in.
So what he was doing was capturing the other angle of the scene on Dwight at the vending machine.
That's right. That's exactly right. And as I was rewatching this scene looking for whose leg is it, I noticed something else.
And it's about Dwight at the vending machine. He has a line where he says, dating a line where he says, dating
advice, why didn't you ask me? And I noticed that Rain pops the tab on his soda between saying
这个。我们是。你准备好了吗？在25分43秒。我看到了那条腿。我看到了那条腿。在做了一些妈妈侦探工作后，我们意识到那是我们的摄像师坐在凳子上，他们经常那样做。他们会有这个小凳子。你知道，我们谈论过它。嗯，我们的墙不会动，所以他们必须坐在角落里。是的，他们必须挤进去。所以他当时在做的是捕捉德怀特在自动售货机旁那个场景的另一个角度。没错。完全正确。当我重看这个场景寻找那是谁的腿时，我注意到了另一件事。那是关于德怀特在自动售货机旁。他有一句台词说，约会建议，为什么你不问我？我注意到雷恩在说
dating advice and why didn't you ask me. And I know why he did that. But let's listen. I want you
guys to just hear this little moment. Wait a minute. Dating advice? Why didn't you ask me? Uh-huh.
Dating advice? Why didn't you ask me? He did that for sound. Because in film and television,
you can never do anything loud on your line or else they can't cut around it.
Also, in the background of that scene, when Rain first enters and he's putting the money in the vending machine and then he gets a soda,
first of all, I'm convinced he's not really putting any money in there because it would have made a sound.
I think he's faky putting coins in.
And then that soda was pre-planted at the bottom of the machine so you wouldn't hear the noise of it going down.
约会建议和为什么你不问我之间弹开了苏打水的拉环。我知道他为什么要那样做。但让我们听听。我希望你们听听这个小瞬间。等一下。约会建议？为什么你不问我？嗯哼。约会建议？为什么你不问我？他是为了声音才那样做的。因为在电影和电视中，你永远不能在台词中做任何大声的事情，否则他们就无法剪辑。此外，在那个场景的背景中，当雷恩第一次进入，他把钱放进自动售货机，然后他拿了一瓶苏打水，首先，我确信他并没有真的放钱进去，因为那会发出声音。我认为他是假装投币。然后那瓶苏打水是预先放在机器底部的，所以你不会听到它掉下来的声音。
Because it would ruin the dialogue at the table.
They need to get one of those vending machines on a set that is the arm that just goes,
those are sometimes loud, though.
Are they?
I don't know.
Not as loud as like the good-ch-go-g-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-oh.
Yeah, yeah, the old-school one.
Yeah.
因为那会毁了桌子上的对话。他们需要在片场弄一台那种手臂会动的自动售货机，那些有时很吵。是吗？我不知道。没有那种“咕咚”声吵。是的，是的，老式的那种。是的。
I love watching the arm.
The arm is kind of cool.
Yeah.
I hear you.
Sometimes I don't even need anything, but I just want to watch the arm.
Oh, so you'll be more likely to buy something out of a vending machine
with an arm than a kuk-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-ch-k-one?
Yes, I love the arm.
我喜欢看那个手臂。那个手臂挺酷的。是的。我听到了。有时我甚至不需要任何东西，但我只是想看那个手臂。哦，所以你比起那种“咕咚”声的机器，更愿意从有手臂的自动售货机里买东西？是的，我喜欢那个手臂。
I don't know, guys.
It's the small things in life.
All right.
Well, acting students out there, that was a hot tip, you know.
So if you have an envelope you have to open, don't open it on your line.
Don't get that soda can on your line.
All the things you learn right here in office, ladies.
Exactly.
我不知道，伙计们。这就是生活中的小事。好吧，外面的表演系学生们，那是一个绝妙的建议。所以如果你有一个信封要打开，不要在你的台词时打开它。不要在你的台词时拿那个苏打罐。所有这些都是你们在《办公室女士》这里学到的。没错。
All right, you guys, thanks for sending in your questions and comments.
Now, please enjoy our second drink of Golden Ticket.
I'm Jenna Fisher.
And I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together.
And we're best friends.
And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you.
Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office
好了，伙计们，感谢你们寄来的问题和评论。现在，请享受我们的第二杯《金奖券》。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你们制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将解析一集《办公室》，
and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
We're the office ladies.
Hello, everyone.
Hi.
Today is Golden Ticket.
Season 5, episode 19.
This was written by Mindy Kaling and directed by Randall Einhorn.
It's a big day for Michael.
并提供只有两个在场的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。大家好。嗨。今天是《金奖券》。第五季，第19集。这是由敏迪·卡灵编剧，兰德尔·艾因霍恩执导的。对迈克尔来说这是重要的一天。
Oh, it's a big idea for Michael.
It's a big idea day for Michael.
Here's your summary.
Michael decides to execute a Willy Wonka-themed promotional idea.
He is going to take some golden tickets.
He's going to hide them in some paper shipments,
and any company that finds a golden ticket gets 10% off.
And it's not limited to one.
哦，这对迈克尔来说是个大主意。这是迈克尔的大主意日。这是你的摘要。迈克尔决定执行一个以威利·旺卡为主题的促销创意。他要拿一些金奖券。他要把它们藏在一些纸张发货中，任何找到金奖券的公司都能获得10%的折扣。而且不限于一张。
Well, we're going to find that out.
Yeah.
This idea is going to backfire.
He is going to pressure Dwight into taking the fall, but then that backfires.
Yeah.
A lot of ideas and a lot of backfires.
A lot of layers here, playing games.
Mm-hmm.
嗯，我们马上就会发现。是的。这个主意会适得其反。他会向德怀特施压让他背锅，但后来这适得其反。是的。很多主意和很多适得其反。这里有很多层次，在玩游戏。嗯哼。
Yeah.
Meanwhile, Pam, Jim, and Andy are all giving dating advice to Kevin.
It's somewhat conflicting.
Kevin's a little confused, but he's going to try to make a connection with
Lynn from Blood Drive from their lonely hearts mixer.
Lynn is still in the mix from the mixer.
Yeah.
Let's get into fast facts.
是的。与此同时，帕姆、吉姆和安迪都在给凯文提供约会建议。这有点矛盾。凯文有点困惑，但他会尝试与《血之驱动》中那个孤独之心联谊会上的琳恩建立联系。琳恩还在联谊会中。是的。让我们进入快速事实。
Fast fact number one, this episode contains maybe one of the most famous office gifts of them all.
You know what I'm talking about.
A jiff?
A jiff for a gif.
It doesn't matter.
You know the one we're talking about.
Is it gif or gif?
I don't know, guys.
快速事实一，这一集包含了也许是所有《办公室》GIF中最著名的一个。你知道我在说什么。Jiff还是Gif？没关系。你知道我们在说哪一个。是Gif还是Gif？我不知道，伙计们。
I've never known.
I'll never know.
Let's ask the two hip young people in the booth.
Please, young people tell us how to say it.
I say Jiff.
What do you say?
No, I say GIF.
Sorry.
我从来不知道。我永远不会知道。让我们问问展位里的两个时髦年轻人。请年轻人告诉我们怎么说。我说Jiff。你说什么？不，我说GIF。抱歉。
I think the correct one is Jif, but it feels wrong.
But everyone I know says GIF.
It's kind of like GIF, but you take the T off.
So I think it's GIF.
Well, I've been saying GIF.
I say GIF.
There you have it.
Also, what's a meme?
我认为正确的是Jif，但感觉不对。但我认识的每个人都说GIF。它有点像GIF，但你去掉T。所以我认为是GIF。嗯，我一直说GIF。我说GIF。就是这样。还有，什么是Meme？
What is a meme?
A GIF is if it moves and a meme is if it's,
Still.
And also, I mean, people say Jiff is correct, but keep in mind, it stands for graphics interchange, whatever the F is.
So it starts with a G.
So it would be GIF, right?
Graphics, G.
Yeah.
什么是Meme？GIF是如果它会动，而Meme是如果它是静止的。而且，我是说，人们说Jiff是正确的，但请记住，它代表图形交换，不管那个F是什么。所以它以G开头。所以应该是GIF，对吧？图形，G。是的。
Right?
We just put a pole in office.
There it is.
Okay.
We'll put a pole, but yeah.
Jiff is a peanut butter.
对吧？我们刚刚在办公室里放了一个投票。就是这样。好的。我们会放一个投票，但是的。好的。好的。Jiff是花生酱。
I'm just saying.
I like it.
You know.
I don't know.
Well, you're putting a pole and since I brought it up, are you a crunchy or a smooth peanut butter?
Smooth.
Same.
Get your peanuts out of my peanut butter.
我只是说说。我喜欢它。你知道。我不知道。嗯，你要放一个投票，既然我提到了，你是喜欢脆花生酱还是滑花生酱？滑的。一样。把你的花生从我的花生酱里拿走。
So there is a very famous GIF.
Or GIF.
Oh, I said it wrong again.
Well, we don't know if you're saying it wrong, lady, but it's true.
When Dwight looks at camera and has his hand up to his face.
It's at the end of the cold open and he says, it's true.
That's everywhere.
It even made it to USA Today's ranking of the top 36 Gifts of the top 36 GIFs of
所以有一个非常著名的GIF。或者GIF。哦，我又说错了。嗯，我们不知道你是不是说错了，女士，但这是真的。当德怀特看着镜头并把手放在脸上时。那是在冷开场结束时，他说：“这是真的。”这到处都是。它甚至进入了《今日美国》排名的前36个GIF，
the office, it's true, was number 13. What's number one? Number one. That's what she said? No, but that's on the list,
but it's not number one. Number one was Michael from the Super Bowl cold open when he says,
oh my God, it's happening. Oh, okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Oh, that's stress relief. Stress relief.
Yeah, where they're doing the fire drill. Yes. Do you want to know what number two is on their list?
is one of my favorites. It might be my number one. Don't throw garbage at my head. No, it's Kelly. It is. I have a lot of
questions. Number one, how dare you? Oh, yeah, that's a good one. But I would like to say that number 12 was
Jim and Pam's air high-five. We made it on the list, so I'm proud of us. I don't know that Angela Martin is on
the list with dialogue, but I'm on every list if you type in eye roll. You've got an eye roll. I've got a
《办公室》的，这是真的，排在第13位。第一名是什么？第一名。那是她说的？不，但在名单上，但不是第一名。第一名是迈克尔在超级碗冷开场时说的，“哦，天哪，它发生了。”哦，好的。是的，是的，是的。哦，那是《压力缓解》。压力缓解。是的，他们在做消防演习。是的。你想知道他们名单上的第二名是什么吗？是我最喜欢的之一。它可能是我的第一名。不要往我头上扔垃圾。不，是凯利。是的。我有很多问题。第一，你怎么敢？哦，是的，那是一个很好的。但我得说第12名是吉姆和帕姆的空中击掌。我们上了名单，所以我为我们感到骄傲。我不知道安吉拉·马丁是否在有对话的名单上，但如果你输入“翻白眼”，我就在每个名单上。你有一个翻白眼。我有一个
I've got an eye roll. And I've got a real good one in this episode, I'm going to point out.
Fast fact number two, speaking of the cold open, which gave us this famous gif, it's all about knock, knock jokes.
The guys are doing these knock, knock jokes with each other. And we'll break it down fully when we get there.
So I watched this episode with Lee, and he said, isn't it amazing how the knock-knock joke is so universal that if one person walks up to another person and says, knock-knock,
You just know to say who's there.
Yeah.
And then you know you're in a knock-knock joke.
How did that begin?
我有一个翻白眼。而且在这一集里我有一个非常好的，我会指出来。快速事实二，说到冷开场，它给了我们这个著名的GIF，全是关于敲门笑话。伙计们在互相讲这些敲门笑话。当我们讲到那里时，我们会完全解析它。所以我看了这一集，李说，敲门笑话如此普遍真是太神奇了，如果一个人走到另一个人面前说，敲门，你就知道要说谁在那儿。是的。然后你就知道你在讲敲门笑话了。那是怎么开始的？
Well.
Uh-oh.
Somebody hit the Google button.
Yes.
As a lady who Googles, I'm going to give you the history of knock-knock jokes.
I want to hear it.
So the first written coupling of knock-knock who's there, the first time it sort of appeared anywhere, people
believe is Shakespeare's Macbeth.
嗯。哦哦。有人按了谷歌按钮。是的。作为一个会用谷歌的女士，我要给你讲讲敲门笑话的历史。我想听听。所以第一次书面结合“敲门，谁在那儿”，第一次它出现在任何地方，人们认为是莎士比亚的《麦克白》。
All roads lead back to Shakespeare.
That's why it was so important to study it in theater school.
Hey, I studied Shakespeare.
I believe you.
But I studied it in my writing class.
Well, there you go.
Act two, scene three, the porter is very hungover, and he has this monologue where he repeats, knock, knock, who's there.
And then he tells you who's there.
条条大路通莎士比亚。这就是为什么在戏剧学校学习它如此重要。嘿，我学习了莎士比亚。我相信你。但我是在写作课上学习的。嗯，就是这样。第二幕，第三场，守门人宿醉很严重，他有一段独白，他重复着，敲门，谁在那儿。然后他告诉你谁在那儿。
He's sort of just kind of in his head.
Tis I, a Montague!
But in this play, it is not a joke.
He's not doing like a jokey thing.
It's not like what it is now.
So now cut to it's the early 1900s.
And there's this new kind of comedy on the scene.
Ooh, what kind?
他有点在自己的脑子里。是我，蒙太古！但在这一出戏里，这不是一个笑话。他不是在做像笑话一样的事情。它不像现在这样。所以现在切到20世纪初。现场出现了一种新的喜剧。哦，哪种？
It's like a call answer comedy or like a bait and response comedy.
And here's an example of one of these jokes from the 1900s.
Someone would say, do you know Arthur?
And that would make the other person say, Arthur Who?
And then you would say, our thermometer.
Oh!
Yes.
That was one of the jokes.
它就像一种呼应喜剧或应答喜剧。这是20世纪这些笑话的一个例子。有人会说，你认识亚瑟吗？那会让另一个人说，亚瑟谁？然后你会说，我们的温度计。哦！是的。那是其中一个笑话。
My kids would love that one, saving it.
Well, it's very similar to that whole updog joke.
The what's up dog.
I don't know.
What's up with you?
Right.
Right?
That Michael famously botched.
我的孩子们会喜欢那个，留着。嗯，它和那个“Updog”笑话非常相似。那个“怎么了，狗”。我不知道。你怎么样？对吧？对吧？迈克尔著名地搞砸了。
So then, in the mid-1930s, this kind of like pun mania morphed into what is now the traditional knock-knock joke.
Cartoonist Bob Doug.
is credited with inventing this joke in its current form.
He wrote a book called Knock Knock Who's There?
And it's basically filled with knock-knock joke puns.
It sold like 2 million copies.
It took off like crazy.
It was a jeopardy question.
所以，在20世纪30年代中期，这种双关语狂热演变成了现在的传统敲门笑话。漫画家鲍勃·道格被认为是这种笑话目前形式的发明者。他写了一本名为《敲门，谁在那儿？》的书。它基本上充满了敲门笑话的双关语。它卖了大约200万册。它火得一塌糊涂。这是一个《危险边缘》的问题。
Get this.
What?
Knock-knock jokes were especially huge in Pennsylvania.
Oh.
Versions of knock-knock jokes started appearing in advertisements.
The Edgemont Cash and Carey grocery store in Chester, Pennsylvania, ran an ad that said,
knock, knock, who's there, Don, Don, Don, who, Don forget to do your shopping at the Cash
and Carry.
听着这个。什么？敲门笑话在宾夕法尼亚州特别流行。哦。敲门笑话的版本开始出现在广告中。宾夕法尼亚州切斯特的埃奇蒙特现金和携带杂货店做了一个广告，说，敲门，谁在那儿，唐，唐，唐，谁，唐忘了在现金和携带店购物。
Yeah, Don forget it.
There was also this one, ready?
Knock knock.
Who's there?
Rufus.
Rufus who.
Roof is the most important part of your house.
That was a roofing company.
是的，唐忘了。还有这个，准备好了吗？敲门。谁在那儿？鲁弗斯。鲁弗斯谁。屋顶是你房子最重要的部分。那是一家屋顶公司。
Okay.
But politicians started using them.
There were like special clubs called knock knock clubs that formed in Illinois and Iowa and Kansas.
And I guess knock knock clubs.
You would just go there and tell your knock knock jokes?
Yes, it was like a place to have a drink and share your greatest knock knock jokes.
Then in 1936 at like the peak of the knock knock joke craze,
There was a song called The Knock Knock Song by Fletcher Henderson, and I'm going to play you a clip.
好的。但政客们开始使用它们。在伊利诺伊州、爱荷华州和堪萨斯州成立了名为“敲门俱乐部”的特殊俱乐部。我想敲门俱乐部。你只是去那里讲你的敲门笑话？是的，它就像一个喝一杯并分享你最棒的敲门笑话的地方。然后在1936年，在敲门笑话热潮的顶峰，有一首名为《敲门歌》的歌，由弗莱彻·亨德森演唱，我要给你放一段片段。
Oh, my word.
Who's there?
Manny.
Mani, mani, thanks to you.
Cecil.
Seesle love music wherever she goes.
Yeah, I love it.
A whole song, full of knock-knock jokes.
哦，我的天。谁在那儿？曼尼。曼尼，曼尼，多亏了你。塞西尔。塞西尔无论走到哪里都喜欢音乐。是的，我喜欢它。整首歌，充满了敲门笑话。
So then, lady, there is a backlash.
Oh, people turn on the knock knock.
Well, all of these psychologists start coming out, like Sigmund Freud.
Uh-oh.
And A.A. Brill.
They start saying that people who have an incessant need to make puns have a psychological
condition.
Oh, no.
所以，女士，出现了反弹。哦，人们开始讨厌敲门笑话。嗯，所有这些心理学家开始出现，比如西格蒙德·弗洛伊德。哦哦。还有A.A.布里尔。他们开始说，那些有不断讲双关语需求的人有一种心理疾病。哦，不。
That it is like a sign of narcissism.
Oh.
A German neurologist named Ottfried Forster said manic punting.
was a certifiable syndrome, and he actually called it Forster's syndrome.
He named it after himself.
I mean...
Aren't you being a narcissist, Mr. Forster?
I mean, I don't know.
这就像是自恋的标志。哦。一位名叫奥特弗里德·福斯特的德国神经学家说，狂躁双关语是一种可证明的综合症，他实际上称之为“福斯特综合症”。他以自己的名字命名。我是说……你不是在自恋吗，福斯特先生？我是说，我不知道。
You're telling me that people that love and pun are a narcissist, and then you name it
after yourself.
That's right.
I just want to point that out.
Yeah.
Well, despite their best efforts, knock-knock jokes have stayed around.
We still have them today.
Of course, they appear in this episode of the office.
你告诉我那些喜欢双关语的人是自恋者，然后你用自己的名字命名它。没错。我只是想指出这一点。是的。嗯，尽管他们尽了最大努力，敲门笑话还是留了下来。我们今天仍然有它们。当然，它们出现在这一集的《办公室》中。
Halloween is coming up. That's when I always hear the knock-knock jokes. I think. It's like with kids. Yeah. What do you got? What do you got? Knock-knock. Who's there? Boo. Boo. Don't cry. It's just a joke. Got it. Do you have any that are, like, what are your favorite? Well, this is the one I remember from elementary school. Knock-knock. Who's there? Banana. Banana. Banana who? Knock-knock. Who's there? Banana. Banana who. Knock-knock. Who's there? Orange. Orange. Orange. Orange.
you glad I didn't say banana. I remember that one too. This is my kids' favorite. What? Knock
Knock. Who's there? Interrupting cow. Oh, my kids like this one too. I know that one.
Interrupting cow. Uh-huh. Yeah. So the lady has Googled. We have gotten to the bottom of the knock-knock joke.
What's your fast fact number three? My fast fact number three is that supposedly coming out in November 2021, there is going to be
a Michael Scott Funko Pop holding a golden ticket. Oh, is it going to be dressed like Willy Wonka?
Yeah, he's going to have a little top hat on. I saw their rendering for it, and I don't know
how accurate it is, but they're saying this is going to be a new Funko Pop based on this episode.
万圣节快到了。那就是我总是听到敲门笑话的时候。我想。就像和孩子们在一起。是的。你有什么？你有什么？敲门。谁在那儿？嘘。嘘。别哭。这只是个笑话。明白了。你有什么喜欢的吗？嗯，这是我小学时记得的。敲门。谁在那儿？香蕉。香蕉。香蕉谁？敲门。谁在那儿？香蕉。香蕉谁。敲门。谁在那儿？橙子。橙子。橙子。橙子，你很高兴我没说香蕉。我也记得那个。这是我孩子们最喜欢的。什么？敲门。谁在那儿？打断牛。哦，我的孩子们也喜欢这个。我知道那个。打断牛。嗯哼。是的。所以女士已经用谷歌搜索过了。我们已经弄清了敲门笑话的底细。你的快速事实三是什么？我的快速事实三是，据说明年11月，将有一个迈克尔·斯科特Funko Pop，手里拿着一张金奖券。哦，他会打扮成威利·旺卡吗？是的，他会戴一顶小礼帽。我看到了他们的渲染图，我不知道它有多准确，但他们说这将是一个基于这一集的新Funko Pop。
Well, that's so fun. I just think they're all so cute. I'm about to get one of Angela in her Fun Run
outfit. You know, I don't have a single Pam Funko Pop. Come on. I don't have one. You got to get one.
I guess I do. I have one of me and my cat, and now I'm going to have a little.
have the fun-ridden one. But that's so cute. The Willy Wonka one is going to be so cute. Well, if you're
into merch from this episode, I also found that you can buy a frameable golden ticket, just like the
one that Michael is putting in the boxes. It was on Amazon. Oh. I don't know why you would want that,
but if you do, it is a veil. If you're having a Willy Wonka themed party. Oh, yeah. Maybe. I was curious.
Do you think Michael is being the Gene Wilder, Wiliwanka, or the Johnny Depp?
嗯，那太有趣了。我只是觉得它们都很可爱。我正要买一个安吉拉穿着Fun Run服装的。你知道，我没有一个帕姆的Funko Pop。得了吧。我没有。你得买一个。我想我得买。我有一个我和我的猫的，现在我要有一个小的。有那个Fun Run的。但这太可爱了。威利·旺卡那个会很可爱。嗯，如果你喜欢这一集的周边，我还发现你可以买一张可装裱的金奖券，就像迈克尔放进盒子里的一样。它在亚马逊上。哦。我不知道你为什么想要那个，但如果你想要，它是有的。如果你要举办威利·旺卡主题派对。哦，是的。也许。我很好奇。你认为迈克尔是吉恩·怀尔德版的威利·旺卡，还是约翰尼·德普版的？
I think he's Gene Wilder.
That's what I thought, too.
But Gene's blazer is purple, and Johnny Depp's is maroon.
And Michael's is maroon.
But he's doing all the somersaults and the dialogue from the Gene Wilder way.
I agree.
Those are all my fast facts.
我认为他是吉恩·怀尔德。我也这么想。但吉恩的西装外套是紫色的，而约翰尼·德普的是栗色的。迈克尔的是栗色的。但他做所有的空翻和对话都是吉恩·怀尔德的方式。我同意。我同意。这些就是我所有的快速事实。
We're going to go to a break.
And when we come back, we have a day.
Delicious surprise. We have a guest. Yes. Oh, we can't wait to talk to him. Oh, I gave a little bit away. Okay, it's a guy. He's tall. And his name is also a weather condition. All right. We'll leave you guessing and then we'll be back.
Is someone on the phone? Hi, it's me, Rain Wilson. Rain Wilson. Rain, what are you doing? Why are you calling us?
Well, I just wanted to see how you guys doing. I missed you. I miss you. I just want to know if you want to know if you want to hang out.
out.
Aw, I do want to hang out.
Great.
我们要去休息一下。当我们回来时，我们有一个美味的惊喜。我们有一位嘉宾。是的。哦，我们迫不及待地想和他谈谈。哦，我泄露了一点点。好的，是个男的。他很高。而且他的名字也是一种天气状况。好的。我们会让你猜，然后我们会回来。有人在电话上吗？嗨，是我，雷恩·威尔森。雷恩·威尔森。雷恩，你在做什么？你为什么要给我们打电话？嗯，我只是想看看你们怎么样。我想你们了。我想你们。我只是想知道你们是否想知道你们是否想聚聚。哦，我确实想聚聚。太棒了。
So when are we getting together?
You tell us.
You know what we want to do, Rain, for reals.
We had this on the text thread.
We want to come to your house and listen to Creed and your son.
Play the guitar.
Play guitar together.
And I want to see your new place and I want to meet your pigs and your Zonky.
那么我们什么时候聚在一起？你告诉我们。你知道我们想做什么，雷恩，说真的。我们在短信里聊过。我们想去你家，听克里德和你儿子一起弹吉他。一起弹吉他。我想看看你的新地方，我想见见你的猪和你的Zonky。
Have you heard about our newest pet sensation?
No.
Oh, the peacock!
We have Alma the peacock.
And now, Rain, did she just walk on up?
did, like, how did Alma get there? So my wife had a horse for a long time named Gus, and Gus was a very old
white Lip-A-Zon horse, and he passed away this summer. He lived a rich full horse life, and he died very
quickly. So that was all fine, but his stall was empty, and they put a vase of flowers in there,
你听说我们最新的宠物轰动了吗？没有。哦，孔雀！我们有阿尔玛这只孔雀。现在，雷恩，她是自己走过来的吗？是的，就像，阿尔玛是怎么到那里的？所以我妻子养了一匹马很长时间，名叫格斯，格斯是一匹非常老的白色利皮扎马，他今年夏天去世了。他过着丰富充实的马生，他走得很快。所以那都很好，但他的马厩空了，他们在里面放了一瓶花，
and it was just kind of left empty as a kind of a salute to old Gus. And two weeks later,
no joke and Gus was white by the way two weeks later out of nowhere sitting in Gus's
horse stall was a white peahen a female peacock oh my goodness no one knows where it came from
it had never been seen there previously it hadn't been seen in the neighborhood or the area of
where my wife's horse where she rides her horses and it just moved in to his stall and so she kind of
trained it to eat feed, and it couldn't stay there because it was spooking some of the horses
because it would flap around and squawk.
And so she trained it to eat feed and go into a carrying container bin, and we took it to our
它就那样空着，作为对老格斯的致敬。两周后，不开玩笑，顺便说一句格斯是白色的，两周后，不知从哪里冒出来，坐在格斯的马厩里的是一只白色的雌性孔雀。哦，天哪，没人知道它从哪里来的，以前从未在那里见过它，在邻居或我妻子骑马的区域也没有见过它，它就搬进了他的马厩，所以她训练它吃饲料，它不能待在那里，因为它会吓到一些马，因为它会拍打翅膀和尖叫。所以她训练它吃饲料并进入一个运输容器箱，我们把它带到了我们的
house, and it made the transition perfectly.
And you guys, Alma is amazing.
And she sleeps during the day when she's not hunting bugs.
She sleeps in the olive tree right outside my office window.
and just scares in at me all day.
So if I'm like podcasting or on Zoom calls or whatever,
I have a white peacock steering into my office.
This is all I could ever hope for, Rain.
家，它过渡得非常完美。伙计们，阿尔玛太棒了。当她不捕虫子时，她白天睡觉。她睡在我办公室窗外的橄榄树里。整天盯着我看。所以如果我在做播客或打Zoom电话什么的，我有一只白孔雀盯着我的办公室。这就是我所能希望的一切，雷恩。
I'm excited about my hummingbirds.
If I had a peacock in my tree, I'd lose it.
I mean, rain, it's Gus.
It's Gus, right?
My friend said if there was ever more proof needed for reincarnation.
Now, I don't know about, I don't know that I buy reincarnation,
but I mean, it was magical.
It's immatical.
我对我的蜂鸟很兴奋。如果我的树上有一只孔雀，我会疯掉的。我是说，雷恩，那是格斯。那是格斯，对吧？我的朋友说，如果还需要更多轮回的证据。现在，我不知道，我不知道我是否相信轮回，但我是说，这太神奇了。这是一种神奇的体验。
experience. It's kind of crazy. Well, there's something happening there. Yeah, I was going to say,
whether you believe in reincarnation or not, there's just something beautiful in the universe that happened
right there. Yeah. Yeah. So besides now our pigs that live at our house, now we have a peacock who is very
demanding. Holly, my wife just went crazy. She bought like a big box arrived yesterday. And I opened it up
and it was filled, I'm not kidding you, it was filled with meal worms. Ew.
Two like 20 pound boxes of bags of mealworms.
Where do you keep those?
Yeah.
这有点疯狂。嗯，那里发生了一些事情。是的，我想说，无论你是否相信轮回，宇宙中确实发生了一些美丽的事情。是的。是的。所以除了现在住在我们家的猪，现在我们有一只非常挑剔的孔雀。霍莉，我妻子简直疯了。她昨天买了一个大箱子。我打开它，里面装满了，我不骗你，装满了粉虫。呃。两箱20磅重的粉虫袋。你把那些放在哪里？是的。
Do you refrigerate them?
Like what do you do with the meal?
Where do you put a meal worm?
You just put them on the ground and then she eats the mealworms.
But in between eating.
Not my wife, the peacock.
The peacock.
We got that part.
你冷藏它们吗？你对粉虫做什么？你把粉虫放在哪里？你只是把它们放在地上，然后她吃粉虫。但在吃的时候。不是我妻子，是孔雀。孔雀。我们明白了那部分。
Well, Ray, listen, we're so excited to have you on.
We know you've been on before and you've sent an audio clips and you're always so supportive.
but we realize there are just some real general questions we ask our guests, and we never got to do that with you.
And here is the one we always lead with. Are you ready?
Okay. Hit me.
All right. So how did you get your job on the office? Is it true that you first auditioned for the role of Michael Scott?
Tell us your office origin story. Oh, I have a great office origin story. I love to tell the story. It's fantastic.
I was starting to do this show six feet under, and I was just at the very beginning of that show.
嗯，雷恩，听着，我们很高兴你能来。我们知道你以前来过，你发过音频片段，你总是那么支持我们。但我们意识到我们问嘉宾的一些真实的一般性问题，我们从来没有和你做过。这是我们总是先问的一个。你准备好了吗？好的。问吧。好的。那么你是怎么得到《办公室》这份工作的？你第一次试镜迈克尔·斯科特这个角色是真的吗？告诉我们你的《办公室》起源故事。哦，我有一个很棒的《办公室》起源故事。我喜欢讲这个故事。太棒了。我当时刚开始做《六尺之下》这部剧，我只是在那部剧的刚开始。
And that was right when HBO was starting to take off.
And it was a very widely, highly regarded show.
And I got cast in this Janine Garofalo comedy pilot for ABC.
And, you know, it was a very small role, but I was like, hey, you know, it's an amazing paycheck.
This is great.
I'm going to be a series regular.
It's my first, like, real stab at a series regular job,
which is a lot better money than doing a guest star,
那是HBO刚开始起飞的时候。那是一部非常受推崇的剧。我在ABC的一部珍妮·加罗法洛喜剧试播集中被选中。而且，你知道，那是一个非常小的角色，但我当时想，嘿，你知道，这是一笔惊人的薪水。这太棒了。我要成为系列常规演员。这是我第一次真正尝试系列常规工作，这比做客串明星赚得多得多，
just for those who are listening and wondering.
And I was very excited about it.
Bob Odenkirk was in it.
Mark Marin was in it.
It had a really kind of great cast.
And I was walking to the table read.
Wait, wait, Rayne, what was it called?
Do you know the name of it?
对于那些正在听并想知道的人。我对此非常兴奋。鲍勃·奥登科克在里面。马克·马龙在里面。它有一个非常棒的演员阵容。我当时正走去参加剧本朗读。等等，等等，雷恩，它叫什么名字？你知道它的名字吗？
Oh, boy.
It'll come to me.
I can't remember right now.
Oh, real life, still life.
Something like that.
I'll look it up.
Okay, go on, go on, go on.
I can't remember.
哦，天哪。它会想起来的。我现在记不起来了。哦，真实生活，静止生活。类似的东西。我会查一下。好的，继续，继续，继续。我记不起来了。
And I was on the way to the table read, which is something that actors you do at the studio or you used to do.
You all sit in a room behind the table and you read it out loud and all the executives are there so they can kind of see the cast together, get their energy, hear the rhythms of the read, give notes, etc.
Very common occurrence.
On my way there, I ran into this NBC executive that I,
I knew at the time, who I had met a couple times. I forget why. And I was like, oh, hi,
it was Vernon, Vernon Sanders. We love Vernon. Yes. Yeah, yeah. He's in Amazon now. And a nice
guy. And I was like, hi, Vernon. And he's like, hi, he's like, what's going on? He goes,
well, I'm so excited because we just landed the rights to the BBC office. And I had seen a couple
我在去剧本朗读的路上，这是演员在工作室做的事情，或者过去常做的事情。你们都坐在桌子后面，大声朗读，所有高管都在那里，这样他们就能看到演员在一起，感受他们的能量，听到朗读的节奏，给出笔记等等。非常普遍的现象。在去那里的路上，我遇到了当时我认识的一位NBC高管，我见过几次。我忘了为什么。我当时想，哦，嗨，是弗农，弗农·桑德斯。我们爱弗农。是的。是的，是的。他现在在亚马逊。一个好人。我当时想，嗨，弗农。他说，嗨，他说，怎么了？他说，嗯，我太兴奋了，因为我们刚刚拿到了BBC《办公室》的版权。我看过几集，
episodes, my friend Sam had them recorded from someone in England on a VHS. It was before they were
like available in the United States. It was really early on. I had seen him and I just loved them.
And I, and outside I was like, oh, that's great. That's great. And inside I was like, oh, God,
damn it. I want to be a match show. That show's so, that show's so awesome. And so I was like,
okay, see you later. Went to the table read. This is one of the most incredible experience.
experiences. In fact, Kent Givorneck was the producer on it. Oh, my gosh. Wow, Kentopedia? Yeah. So we did the table read, and this was an infamous
event. We did the table read. It went so bad that the plug was pulled immediately. They canceled it? You didn't even
shoot it? They didn't even shoot it. They had sets built. We had plane tickets. We had hotel rooms booked. I was
我的朋友萨姆从英国某人那里录制在VHS上。那是在它们在美国可用之前。那真的很早。我看过，我只是喜欢它们。我在外面说，哦，那太棒了。那太棒了。但在心里我想，哦，天哪，该死。我想成为那个节目的一部分。那个节目太棒了。所以我当时想，好的，再见。去了剧本朗读。这是最不可思议的经历之一。事实上，肯特·吉沃内克是那里的制片人。哦，天哪。哇，肯特百科？是的。所以我们做了剧本朗读，这是一个臭名昭著的事件。我们做了剧本朗读。它进行得太糟糕了，插头立即被拔掉了。他们取消了？你甚至没拍？他们甚至没拍。他们建了布景。我们有飞机票。我们预订了酒店房间。我
supposed to fly the next morning and then start shooting in like two days. And the table read went so poorly.
We found the name, by the way. The name is slice oh life. Slice oh life. That's what I knew it had
life in it and an S. So all of a sudden I was free to do the office. So I called my agents. I was like,
I'd really like to audition for this office. And yes, I was I was the first person to audition on the very
first day, Allison Jones, the casting director, kind of knew me from six feet under and some other things.
I was so excited. And I auditioned for both Dwight and Michael on that first day. And she keeps
threatening to release my Michael Scott audition. It is truly terrible because I just did a Ricky
Jerva's impersonation. I didn't know what else to do. So I was kind of pulling on my tie a lot.
本应第二天早上飞，然后在两天内开始拍摄。剧本朗读进行得太糟糕了。顺便说一句，我们找到了名字。名字是《Slice o Life》。《Slice o Life》。我知道它里面有生活和S。所以突然之间我有空做《办公室》了。所以我打电话给我的经纪人。我当时想，我真的很想试镜这个《办公室》。是的，我是第一天第一个试镜的人，选角导演艾莉森·琼斯从《六尺之下》和其他一些事情中认识我。我太兴奋了。我在第一天试镜了德怀特和迈克尔。她一直威胁要发布我的迈克尔·斯科特试镜。它真的太糟糕了，因为我只是模仿了瑞奇·热维斯。我不知道还能做什么。所以我当时一直在拉我的领带。
And it was, but Dwight, I knew, I was like, this is completely in my wheelhouse.
I know exactly who this person is.
This guy is in my DNA.
I have cousins who are really not that different from Dwight Shrewd.
And the rest is history.
Well, Rayne, I remember being paired with you during the screen tests.
Yeah.
And they were mixing and matching us.
而且，但德怀特，我知道，我当时想，这完全在我的能力范围内。我完全知道这个人是谁。这个家伙在我的DNA里。我有表亲和德怀特·施鲁特真的没什么不同。剩下的就是历史了。嗯，雷恩，我记得在屏幕测试期间和你配对。是的。他们把我们混在一起。
There were like four pams and four gyms and.
and Bord-Dwights and a few Michaels.
Bob Odenkirk was one of the Michaels,
which is so crazy because I guess he was available as well
since Slico Life didn't go forward.
And Ken's Brunach was available.
Yeah, wow, we really got a lot of folks from Slico Life.
We got lucky there.
有四个帕姆，四个吉姆，还有德怀特和几个迈克尔。鲍勃·奥登科克是迈克尔之一，这太疯狂了，因为我想既然《Slice o Life》没继续，他也空闲。肯·斯布鲁纳赫也空闲。是的，哇，我们真的从《Slice o Life》里得到了很多人。我们很幸运。
We scored.
But, Ray, I remember being paired with you,
and I mean, I couldn't believe it.
Of all of us, of all of us,
you were 100% there from the beginning.
I feel like from that moment that I did that first audition scene with you.
Everybody else, I was paired with John and I was like, oh yeah, this is great.
And Steve and everybody.
我们得分了。但是，雷恩，我记得和你配对，我是说，我简直不敢相信。在我们所有人中，你从一开始就100%在那里。我觉得从我和你做第一次试镜场景的那一刻起。其他人，我和约翰配对，我当时想，哦，是的，这太棒了。还有史蒂夫和每个人。
But Rain, you were just like, I didn't even know where rain began and Dwight ended or Dwight began and rain ended.
I mean, it was so fluid.
It was amazing.
But you were, I have to say this.
Mutual Admiration Society.
For those who don't know, Jenna was totally in Pam, dressed as Pam.
You were reading the book on John Belushi, Wired, that you thought Pam would be reading.
It was in the script that she was reading it.
但雷恩，你只是，我甚至不知道雷恩从哪里开始，德怀特在哪里结束，或者德怀特从哪里开始，雷恩在哪里结束。我是说，它太流畅了。太神奇了。但我必须说这个。互助协会。对于那些不知道的人，珍娜完全穿着帕姆的衣服。你当时在读关于约翰·贝鲁西的书《Wired》，你认为帕姆会读。剧本里写着她在读它。
So I read the whole novel.
I read the whole thing.
I was like, my character read it.
I'll read it.
Yeah.
And you were Pam in the waiting room, too.
But that was so much fun.
And we had, I don't know if they'd ever released that audition, but that improvisation where I was just sitting, I was kneeling like way too close to you.
所以我读了整本小说。我读了整本。我当时想，我的角色读了它。我会读它。是的。你在候诊室里也是帕姆。但这太有趣了。我们有，我不知道他们是否发布过那个试镜，但那个即兴表演，我当时只是坐着，我跪得离你太近了。
Yeah.
Like, which is something I love to do as Dwight is like he doesn't have an understanding of like personal space.
He does not.
He could be talking to someone like four inches away from them.
And I thought, I thought that was really funny.
And where I talked about my girlfriend being stationed in Kuwait.
and that was very funny.
And it was such a great improv because most actors feel like, oh, I'm improvving.
是的。就像，这是我作为德怀特喜欢做的事情，他没有个人空间的概念。他没有。他可以和离他四英寸远的人说话。我觉得这真的很有趣。我谈到我的女朋友驻扎在科威特。那非常有趣。这是一个很棒的即兴表演，因为大多数演员觉得，哦，我在即兴表演。
I need to talk a lot.
They think like, oh, improvisation means talking a lot.
And this was an improv where I kind of did this monologue, and you just gazed painfully into space
taking in my body odor and my proximity and the strangeness of my story.
And it was fantastic.
we did that, I was like, oh, I know that we're going to have these parts.
Yeah.
I felt that way, too, and I felt at that audition, it was very clear to me that you were their choice.
我需要说很多话。他们觉得，哦，即兴表演意味着要说很多话。那是一次即兴表演，我做了一段独白，而你就痛苦地凝视着虚空，忍受着我的体味、我的靠近以及我故事的怪异。那真是太棒了。我们做到了，我当时就想，哦，我知道我们会有这些部分。是的。我也那种感觉，而且在试镜时，我很清楚你就是他们的选择。
Did they keep pairing different people with Rain?
Because that's how you know.
You know that's the person when they're like, oh, let's see him with this person and this
person and this person.
And I only got paired with him once, and that made me a little nervous because it was
very clear to me that Rain had the part.
And so I was like, oh, well, can I, I'm, I'll pair with him again?
a lot of different gyms. I remember reading with a lot of different gyms.
他们有没有一直让不同的人和雷恩搭档？因为这就是你怎么知道的。你知道那个人就是你要找的，当他们说，哦，让我们看看他和这个人、那个人还有那个人搭档时。我只和他搭档过一次，这让我有点紧张，因为我很清楚雷恩已经拿到了那个角色。所以我当时想，哦，好吧，我能，我，我能再和他搭档一次吗？很多不同的吉姆。我记得和很多不同的吉姆一起读过剧本。
Yeah. And the reason they said ultimately they went with John, I mean, obviously he's charming and
handsome and funny and great deadpan and smart as hell and likable, but that his size was
comparable to mine. There were a couple other gyms that were like 5'7 and it just seemed like
Dwight would just overpower them. The gym was actually taller than me. So we kind of like, we really
matched up kind of energy-wise.
That makes sense to me.
Yeah.
That does.
是的。他们最终选择约翰的原因，我的意思是，显然他很有魅力、英俊、风趣、擅长冷幽默，而且聪明绝顶、讨人喜欢，但他的体型和我的相当。还有其他几个吉姆，身高只有5英尺7英寸，看起来德怀特会完全压制他们。那个吉姆实际上比我高。所以我们在能量上真的很匹配。这对我来说很有道理。是的。确实如此。
But then they went a whole other way with your romantic life, and they picked the tiniest person in the office.
Tiniest, the tiniest little sprig.
Yeah, but I didn't think they knew that Dwight and Angela were going to get together.
They just were, I don't know where that storyline came from, but I imagine they were just
kind of floundering in season two.
Like, oh, we've got to mix things up.
Like, because at first they had me together with Kelly, they had me kiss.
Kelly Kapoor.
但后来他们在你的浪漫生活上走了另一条路，他们选择了办公室里最娇小的人。最娇小，最娇小的一小枝。是的，但我认为他们当时不知道德怀特和安吉拉会在一起。他们只是，我不知道那个故事情节是怎么来的，但我猜他们在第二季时只是有点不知所措。就像，哦，我们得搞点新花样。因为起初他们让我和凯莉在一起，他们让我吻了凯莉·卡普尔。
But Angela was furious.
Angela watched it and was furious.
Remember, they had me, like, look in the camera.
Like, they made me look so, like, they kept saying, more anger, more.
I was like, my God, my eyes are going to pop out of my head.
But I think our writers just sat there.
Jen and I have talked about this, and we've talked to our writers about it, how they would just take two names and put them on a card and just see what that felt like and sort of spitball a little bit about what those two people would bring out.
of each other. Right. And that is one thing that Greg talked about, and I remember, and it's
但安吉拉很愤怒。安吉拉看了之后非常愤怒。记得吗，他们让我，比如，看向镜头。他们让我看起来非常，比如，他们一直说，再愤怒一点，再多一点。我当时想，天哪，我的眼珠都要掉出来了。但我认为我们的编剧只是坐在那里。珍和我也谈过这个，我们也和编剧谈过，他们会把两个名字写在卡片上，看看那是什么感觉，然后随便聊聊这两个人会激发出对方什么特质。对。这是格雷格谈到的一点，我记得，而且这是
really great lesson for comedy writers and screenwriters. He said, a lot of shows really focus on a
character and like, oh, let's make this character really specific and funny and interesting.
But he was really about like, when these two characters bang up against each other,
that's what she said. Then what do... What happens? What happens with that energy?
You know, so it was more about, he was much more about dynamics between characters.
And I think that's one of the successes of the authors.
Well, this episode that we're talking about today, Golden Ticket, has a classic Michael Dwight pairing.
And we just, I love in this rewatch watching the way that Dwight can be both Michael's lackey and then also, like, you can take him to task.
对喜剧编剧和剧作家来说非常棒的一课。他说，很多剧集真的专注于一个角色，比如，哦，让我们让这个角色变得非常具体、有趣和引人入胜。但他真正关注的是，当这两个角色碰撞在一起时，这就是她所说的。那么会发生什么？那种能量会产生什么？你知道，所以他更多的是关于角色之间的动态。我认为这是作者们成功的原因之一。好吧，我们今天谈论的这一集《金奖券》，有经典的迈克尔和德怀特配对。我喜欢在重温时观察德怀特既能做迈克尔的走狗，又能对他提出批评的方式。
You stand up to him.
what was that like for you?
You were in this comedy duo with Steve Corel for seven years, playing out moments like this.
What was that experience?
Well, that's a bunch of questions.
I know.
That's how I like to interview people.
She just likes to throw like 13, big overarching, like huge questions.
你对他挺身而出。那对你来说是什么感觉？你和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔搭档了七年，演绎了这样的时刻。那是什么样的经历？好吧，那是一堆问题。我知道。我就是喜欢这样采访别人。她就是喜欢抛出13个宏大的、概括性的、巨大的问题。
Yeah, thematic questions all at once.
I love it.
Well, let me hit that one.
Let me just say that.
you know, when I look back on that work with Steve,
I'm just so grateful
because he's obviously like one of the greatest
actors, comedy actors, but even just actors like ever.
是的，一次性抛出所有主题性问题。我喜欢。好吧，让我回答那个。让我说，你知道，当我回顾和史蒂夫一起工作时，我感到非常感激，因为他显然是有史以来最伟大的演员之一，喜剧演员，甚至仅仅作为演员。
And the fact that I got to do so much work with him
was just such a gift.
I didn't come from an improv background.
I was always good at improv, but I wouldn't
at theater school and I did Shakespeare
and I did Eugene O'Neill
and I was in New York kind of
off-Broadway theater
能和他一起做这么多工作真是一份礼物。我不是即兴表演出身。我一直擅长即兴表演，但我没去过戏剧学校，我演过莎士比亚，演过尤金·奥尼尔，我在纽约算是外百老汇戏剧
guy and Steve was from Second City
and had done years and years and years of
improv so that was his
thing.
But the thing about Steve
that I'll, you know they always have this
it's kind of become a cliche like the yes and
you know like an improv
演员，而史蒂夫来自第二城剧团，做了多年多年的即兴表演，所以那是他的强项。但关于史蒂夫，我会说，你知道他们总是说这个，这已经成为一种陈词滥调，比如“是的，而且”，你知道，在即兴表演中
if you say like hey
you know
I bought a pet peacock
then you say yes and and like, oh, I'd love to see it.
Can I feed it my mealworms or whatever?
And Steve was incredible at that, no matter what I did.
And sometimes I would try to go really out of the box.
Steve would completely react in character and accept what was being proposed.
如果你说，嘿，你知道我买了一只宠物孔雀，那么你会说“是的，而且”，比如，哦，我很想看看它。我能喂它吃我的粉虫或者别的什么吗？史蒂夫在这方面非常出色，无论我做什么。有时我会尝试跳出常规。史蒂夫会完全以角色的身份做出反应，并接受所提出的建议。
So I could just in the, because obviously we would shoot a scene, we would improvise,
I mean, we would do the script.
We would shoot the script and make sure we got it scripted correctly.
And then we could improvise.
And then sometimes it would just, we'd just freely improvise and just go off.
And I remember just being like I could say something like,
I decided to open a llama farm just out of nowhere or something.
And Steve would just listen as Michael, take that in and be like,
所以我可以，因为显然我们会拍摄一个场景，我们会即兴发挥，我的意思是，我们会按照剧本演。我们会拍摄剧本，确保我们正确地按照剧本执行。然后我们可以即兴发挥。有时我们会自由地即兴发挥，然后跑题。我记得我当时想，我可以随口说些什么，比如我决定开一个羊驼农场，或者类似的事情。史蒂夫会以迈克尔的身份倾听，接受它，然后说，
Dwight, what are you talking about llamas?
What does that have to do with anything?
Why?
You're so weird.
Dwight, go away, you're icky.
Like, and it would just be completely in the moment.
And I just learned so much from that process.
He never got kind of like,
德怀特，你在说什么羊驼？那和任何事情有什么关系？为什么？你太奇怪了。德怀特，走开，你真恶心。就像那样，完全沉浸在当下。我从那个过程中学到了很多。他从来没有那种，
goddamn it, Rain, why are you being so weird and so silly?
Like, stay on the point of the scene.
And we could go way off filter, you know, way off the path.
And he would just be right there all the time.
It was really a privilege.
to work with him.
I loved it when there'd be a conference room scene, and clearly Michael had an agenda and things to say.
And you, you as Dwight, of all people, would interject, right?
该死的，雷恩，你为什么这么奇怪，这么傻？就像，保持在场景的重点上。我们可以完全偏离轨道，你知道，完全偏离路径。但他总是会在那里。能和他一起工作真是一种荣幸。我喜欢会议室的场景，显然迈克尔有议程和要说的事情。而你，作为德怀特，竟然会插话，对吧？
And, Rain, so many times I go to the script to see if it was written or improvised,
because I feel like I can tell now.
And they're always so good, but it's like seamless.
You would never know because of exactly what you just shared, because Steve is Michael.
no matter what you piped up and said, just like would just take it and run with it.
And it was always like an absolute joy.
You know me.
I'm a nerdy, nerdy improv gal.
而且，雷恩，很多次我去看剧本，想看看那是写好的还是即兴的，因为我觉得我现在能分辨出来。它们总是那么好，但就像无缝衔接一样。你永远不会知道，正是因为你刚才分享的，因为史蒂夫就是迈克尔。无论你插嘴说了什么，他都会接受并顺着演下去。那总是一种绝对的快乐。你知道我。我是个书呆子，书呆子即兴表演迷。
We've talked on the podcast that you and Jenna had your whole, like, we did theater.
And Jenna likes to remind me of it, Rain, much like you did.
But as like a nerdy improv gal watching you guys, it was just awesome.
I felt like I had a front row seat of just some really memorable.
magical moments. And getting specifically to Golden Ticket, thank you, Angela. And but yeah, I hadn't
seen this one since it came out. And it was so fun to watch. And Jenna, just like you said,
that dynamic of Dwight being TOTie, lackey, suck up, just so desperate for Michael's approval.
and then oddly realizing he's got some power here.
我们在播客里谈过，你和珍娜有你们的整个，比如，我们演过戏剧。珍娜喜欢提醒我这一点，雷恩，就像你做的那样。但作为一个书呆子即兴表演迷看着你们，那真是太棒了。我觉得我坐在前排，见证了一些非常难忘的、神奇的时刻。说到《金奖券》，谢谢你，安吉拉。但是是的，自从它播出后我就没看过这一集了。看这一集真的很有趣。珍娜，就像你说的，德怀特那种既是走狗、马屁精，又如此渴望迈克尔认可的动态，然后奇怪地意识到他在这里有一些权力。
And, you know, that switch when he's shaking David Wallace's hand and he says, you know,
thank you and takes the credit for it.
And then Steve's expression of it was so priceless of like, oh, that guy.
And then your fight in the marketing meeting.
Like when you get on the phone with the marketing guys, the two of you back and forth with your big ideas.
Yeah, horse boats and all the toilet net gives a lot of toilet ideas.
You don't have ideas. Yes, I do. I would love to see an extended cut of that because I bet that there were a lot more ideas we tossed back and forth in that scene.
We should ask Dave Rogers, the keeper of all of the extra footage, because I bet you're right. There had to have been even more.
而且，你知道，当他握住大卫·华莱士的手并说，你知道，谢谢你，并把功劳揽在自己身上时，那个转变。然后史蒂夫的表情真是无价之宝，就像，哦，那个家伙。还有你们在营销会议上的争吵。就像当你们和营销人员通电话时，你们两个来回争论你们的大点子。是的，马船，还有所有的厕所网，给了很多厕所点子。你没有点子。我有。我很想看那一幕的加长版，因为我敢打赌我们在那一幕中抛出了更多的点子。我们应该问问戴夫·罗杰斯，所有额外镜头的保管人，因为我敢打赌你是对的。肯定还有更多。
Also, this one was written by Mindy Kaling, and she was amazing at coming up with on the fly in the moment extra stuff to hand you.
I have to tell you guys, in the script, I reread it, Pam tries to butt in with an idea.
What?
Yes.
And Michael and Dwight shoot her down.
It's the one thing they agree on is that Pam's idea is so stupid.
She says, as they're yelling all their ideas, Pam meekly just says,
remote control toilets.
另外，这一集是由敏迪·卡灵写的，她非常擅长在现场即兴想出额外的东西交给你。我必须告诉你们，在剧本里，我重读了一遍，帕姆试图插话提出一个点子。什么？是的。迈克尔和德怀特拒绝了她。他们唯一达成一致的事情就是帕姆的点子太蠢了。她说，当他们大喊大叫他们的点子时，帕姆温顺地说，遥控马桶。
And they're both like,
nah, it's stupid.
Doesn't make sense.
It's dumb.
That's great.
I wish they would have kept that.
We have another question
他们俩都说，不，太蠢了。没意义。太笨了。那太棒了。我希望他们能保留那个。那太棒了。我们还有另一个问题
that we've never asked you, Rain.
This is a popular one we ask all our guests.
Okay.
Did you take anything from set when the show wrapped?
Oh, this breaks my heart.
I should have taken so much more.
I should have fleeced NBC Universal.
I took Dwight's glasses.
我们从来没问过你，雷恩。这是我们问所有嘉宾的一个热门问题。好的。剧集结束时你从片场拿走了什么吗？哦，这让我心碎。我应该拿走更多东西的。我应该洗劫NBC环球的。我拿走了德怀特的眼镜。
I took his little desk plate that said Dwight Shrewt on it.
I took his stapler.
And one or two other things I can't quite remember.
I have to look around and see.
But I had a whole list of things I gave to Phil Shea.
And I said, Phil, pull these aside from me.
And I'll get them from you later.
And it was, you know, Dwight's briefcase and this.
我拿走了他那个写着“德怀特·施鲁特”的小桌牌。我拿走了他的订书机。还有一两件我不记得了。我得四处看看才知道。但我有一份清单，我给了菲尔·谢。我说，菲尔，把这些留给我。我以后再从你那拿。那是，你知道，德怀特的公文包还有这个。
and that and the other thing and blah blah blah and um and phil was like okay and then i went back to
phil and he's like oh i don't have um or i couldn't get them sorry blah blah blah and then i
heard from someone else they were like oh they threatened the crew like to be fired and never
worked for NBC Universal again if they caught them taking anything from the office
and we didn't know why and then they had that big option where
they auctioned all the stuff off on eBay.
You know, even like Dwight's desk was auctioned off.
Did you not get your bobblehead?
那个，还有别的东西，等等等等，然后菲尔说好的，然后我回去找菲尔，他说，哦，我没有，或者我拿不到，抱歉等等，然后我从别人那里听说，他们说，哦，他们威胁剧组人员，如果抓到他们从办公室拿走任何东西，就会被解雇，再也不能为NBC环球工作，我们不知道为什么，然后他们举行了那场大型拍卖会，在eBay上拍卖了所有东西。你知道，甚至德怀特的桌子都被拍卖了。你没拿到你的摇头娃娃吗？
I got one of the rejected bobbleheads that doesn't look anything like the bobbled.
I'd not get my original bobblehead, no.
I see.
And I have to feel shade for the painting.
The Dwight painting was kind of where he's like Chairman Mao.
Yeah, yeah.
And that didn't happen either.
Well, Rain, you know, you've gone on to do so many awesome things, but we would love to talk to you about your podcast, Metaphysical Milkshake.
我拿到了一个被拒绝的摇头娃娃，看起来一点也不像摇头娃娃。我没拿到我原来的摇头娃娃，没有。我明白了。我得为那幅画感到遗憾。德怀特的那幅画有点像他是毛主席。是的，是的。那也没发生。好吧，雷恩，你知道，你后来做了很多很棒的事情，但我们很想和你谈谈你的播客《形而上学的奶昔》。
I listened to a great episode last night when you had Mike Shirt on.
Yeah.
And that was so amazing just talking about what is good, what is bad.
And he sort of like folded in his show The Good Place Into that episode.
But you and Reza are so thoughtful and you're really asking life's big questions.
And it's a great listen.
Yeah, thanks. Well, you guys know this is something that's always been really important to me. And it was kind of the impetus and inspiration for starting Soul Pancake, the digital media company that we, I created with some friends. But this whole idea of life's biggest possible questions has always really intrigued me. You know, I took philosophy in college and I love, you know, studying spirituality. And I love, you know, psychology and sociology.
and kind of creativity and how creativity works and why.
昨晚我听了一集很棒的节目，你请了迈克·舒尔。是的。谈论什么是好，什么是坏，真是太神奇了。他把他的剧集《善地》融入到了那一集中。但你和礼萨非常深思熟虑，你们真的在问人生的大问题。这是一个很棒的节目。是的，谢谢。好吧，你们知道这对我来说一直很重要。这也是我创办Soul Pancake的动力和灵感，这是我和一些朋友创建的数字媒体公司。但关于人生最大问题的整个想法一直让我很着迷。你知道，我在大学学过哲学，我喜欢，你知道，研究灵性。我喜欢，你知道，心理学和社会学。还有创造力以及创造力是如何运作的，为什么。
And so this was kind of the foundation for metaphysical milkshake.
Our first season we did on this company called Luminary,
but that didn't really work out.
So now we're doing a second season,
which is available wherever podcasts are available
and including a lot of the stuff we did for our first season.
And it's super fun.
We get to talk to just artists and thinkers and writers.
所以这就是《形而上学的奶昔》的基础。我们的第一季是在一家叫Luminary的公司做的，但那没成功。所以现在我们正在做第二季，可以在任何有播客的地方收听，包括我们在第一季做的很多内容。这超级有趣。我们有机会和艺术家、思想家和作家交谈。
We just yesterday interviewed Avi Loeb, who's the head of the astronomy division of Harvard University, talking about alien life and discovering extraterrestrial life.
And then we had Jason, speaking of office auction, Jason Isbell is one of my favorite kind of country rock.
I love him.
Yeah, he's so great.
He came on the show talking about like what music is, like where does music come from?
Oh, I need to go listen to that one.
He bought years ago, he bought his wife, Dwight's scissors from the NBC auction.
Whoa.
我们昨天刚采访了哈佛大学天文学系主任阿维·勒布，谈论外星生命和发现地外生命。然后我们有杰森，说到办公室拍卖，杰森·伊斯贝尔是我最喜欢的乡村摇滚歌手之一。我喜欢他。是的，他太棒了。他来到节目中谈论音乐是什么，比如音乐从哪里来？哦，我得去听听那一集。他几年前买了他妻子的，从NBC拍卖会上买的德怀特的剪刀。哇。
Isn't that crazy?
Yes.
Well, Rain, I listened to your interview with Adam Grant, where you discussed this concept,
what if I'm wrong?
And this idea, our resistance as people to consider that you might be wrong,
or even what I loved when you guys talked about how when you know you're wrong, but the cost of
admitting you're wrong, that idea of like there's that social cost, oh, no, if I admit I'm wrong
once, people will paint me with a brush that, oh, that's the person who gets things wrong.
那不是很疯狂吗？是的。好吧，雷恩，我听了你对亚当·格兰特的采访，你们讨论了这个概念，如果我错了怎么办？这个想法，我们作为人拒绝考虑你可能错了，或者甚至我喜欢你们讨论的，当你明知自己错了，但承认错误的代价，那种社会代价，哦，不，如果我承认我错了，人们会给我贴上标签，哦，那就是那个总是出错的人。
I mean, it was just, it was so thoughtful.
I love that kind of introspective discussion that makes me think about things that maybe I wouldn't
of thought of otherwise. It's a great podcast. You know, I'm glad you brought that one up because I feel
like this is kind of where our country is. It's very stuck in kind of two sides that are convinced
they're 100% right and no one's really talking to each other and learning and listening from
each other. And when you go to life's biggest questions, these are the questions that we've been
asking since the caveman days, since ancient Greece, you know, why are we alive? Do we have free will?
what's the meaning of it all.
我的意思是，这太深思熟虑了。我喜欢那种让我思考我原本可能不会想到的事情的内省讨论。这是一个很棒的播客。你知道，我很高兴你提到了那个，因为我觉得这就是我们国家现在的处境。它非常卡在两种观点中，双方都确信自己是100%正确的，没有人真正地在交谈、学习和倾听对方。当你谈到人生最大的问题时，这些是我们从穴居人时代、从古希腊以来一直在问的问题，你知道，我们为什么活着？我们有自由意志吗？这一切的意义是什么。
And these discussions can unite us.
So that's really the whole purpose is to unite people by getting young folks thinking about
talking, wrestling with, you know, the human experience.
Well, Rain, at the end of your podcast with Reza, you guys do this sort of rapid fire of questions.
And I love when you ask people, when do you most feel connected to the universe?
I'm paraphrasing, but it's something like that question, right?
So when do you, Rain feel most connected to the universe?
Wow, you're okay.
这些讨论可以团结我们。所以这确实是全部目的，通过让年轻人思考、交谈、与人类经验搏斗来团结人们。好吧，雷恩，在你的播客结束时，你和礼萨会进行这种快速问答。我喜欢你问人们，你什么时候最感到与宇宙相连？我在转述，但大概是那个问题，对吧？那么你，雷恩，什么时候感到最与宇宙相连？哇，你，好吧。
You're hitting me with my own weapon.
That's what she said.
That's a profound question.
And wow, no one's ever asked me that before.
You know, so I meditate.
That's part of my daily practice.
But I'll have a new answer to that,
is I've gotten really, really deep into tennis.
你用我自己的武器攻击我。这就是她所说的。这是一个深刻的问题。哇，从来没有人问过我这个问题。你知道，我冥想。这是我日常练习的一部分。但我会有一个新的答案，我已经深入研究网球了。
Oh.
And we joined a tennis club in this new little town that I moved to in California.
And I've been playing a lot two, three times a week.
And there's something really incredible about the game of tennis because it requires such
focus that when you're playing it, you're just completely in the moment.
You have to be completely in the moment, or you will screw it.
up and hit the ball out. So it forces a kind of, like a focus. And that allows one to be, like,
connected. When I'm playing tennis, like, time doesn't really exist in the same way that exists in my
哦。我们搬到的加州这个新小镇加入了一个网球俱乐部。我一直在打球，每周两三次。网球这项运动有一些非常不可思议的地方，因为它需要如此专注，以至于当你打球时，你完全沉浸在当下。你必须完全沉浸在当下，否则你会搞砸，把球打出界。所以它强迫一种，比如，专注。这让人能够，比如，连接起来。当我打网球时，时间并不像在我的
regular life. My anxieties go away. And I know that's not a terribly profound one, but I have
truly been felt feeling connected to the universe through tennis. I think that's great because I think
for me, I have to get out of my head sometimes and get in my body. You know, when I get nervous or
anxious about something, I stop everything, I put screens away. You know I love tennis as well,
but I like to just get in my body somehow, whether that's a hike or just going on a long walk,
just anything to just get back in my body and get out of my head. And, and, and, and, and, and,
And I just love that. Rain, do you remember working on my serve with me on the side of our sound
stage? I had my racket and I was telling you I was struggling with my serve. And so we went to
正常生活中那样存在。我的焦虑消失了。我知道这不是一个非常深刻的答案，但我确实通过网球感受到了与宇宙的连接。我认为这很棒，因为我认为对我来说，我有时必须跳出我的头脑，进入我的身体。你知道，当我对某事感到紧张或焦虑时，我会停止一切，把屏幕收起来。你知道我也喜欢网球，但我喜欢以某种方式进入我的身体，无论是徒步旅行还是长距离散步，只要能让我回到身体里，跳出头脑就行。而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且，而且我就是喜欢那样。雷恩，你还记得在我们的摄影棚边上教我发球吗？我拿着球拍，告诉你我在发球方面很挣扎。所以我们去了
the side of the building where the hair and makeup trailers were. And you had me work on my toss
and then I would hit it onto the side of the building. And you told me my toss was horrible.
It was like all about my toss. My toss wasn't high enough. Did you feel connected to the
universe, as Rain told you, your toss was horrible, Angela. I felt frustrated, but connected.
It's so funny. Isn't it funny how it must be old age? I have no memory of that. But that's incredible.
That's incredible. How is your serve these days? You know what? It's much better. It's much better. I do
toss higher. But I also throw myself at it in a way I didn't before. Maybe it's like being 50 and
having, you know, like the past few years of like just like craziness, I throw myself at that ball
大楼边上，那里有发型和化妆拖车。你让我练习抛球，然后我把它打到大楼侧面。你告诉我我的抛球太糟糕了。这完全是关于我的抛球。我的抛球不够高。当雷恩告诉你你的抛球很糟糕时，你感到与宇宙相连了吗，安吉拉？我感到沮丧，但感到连接。这太有趣了。这不是很滑稽吗，一定是老了？我对此毫无记忆。但这太不可思议了。这太不可思议了。你最近的发球怎么样？你知道吗？好多了。好多了。我确实抛得更高了。但我也会以一种以前没有的方式投入其中。也许就像50岁了，经历了过去几年的疯狂，我以一种以前没有的方式投入到那个球中
in a way I haven't before. And my tennis coach is like, I got some power there, Angie. He calls
me Angie. Nice. Wow. Fantastic. It's a, I'm like low to the ground, Rain. I've got a good torque.
That is so weird. You guys, what a pleasure being on your show. And thanks for the deep dive. And God,
what an amazing pleasure it was watching Golden Ticket again.
That cold open, too, the KGB and the Knopf jokes.
It was so good.
There's so many classic office moments throughout it.
I have to ask, since you brought it up,
。我的网球教练说，我那里有力量，安吉。他叫我安吉。不错。哇。太棒了。我，我像贴近地面一样，雷恩。我有很好的扭矩。这太奇怪了。你们，能上你们的节目真是荣幸。谢谢你们的深入探讨。天哪，再次观看《金奖券》真是太令人愉快了。那个冷开场也是，克格勃和诺夫的笑话。太棒了。整个过程中有这么多经典的办公室时刻。我必须问，既然你提到了，
how did you guys get through that cold open with slapping each other?
I mean, because if you broke, you'd have to do it again.
And obviously, you didn't want to have to keep slapping and getting slapped.
but I mean, how'd you do it?
People always ask like, how do you keep a straight face?
It's like, I didn't keep a straight face.
You didn't, Rain.
You didn't because I watched the bloopers and you are one of the top breakers.
你们是怎么拍完那个互相扇耳光的冷开场的？我的意思是，因为如果你笑场了，你就得重拍。显然，你不想一直扇人和被扇。但我的意思是，你们是怎么做到的？人们总是问，你怎么保持严肃的表情？就像，我没保持严肃。你没有，雷恩。你没有，因为我看了花絮，你是最容易笑场的人之一。
I would just laugh all the time, especially John and I, we would just make each other laugh.
We could look at each other's eyes and know a laugh was coming.
So I don't remember, but I am certain that especially that little last section when John was like doing the KGB that I
I'm sure I was crying with laughter and we had to cut, you know, at least a dozen times.
I also, I mean, listen, the book end of this is that it starts with the KGB and it ends with
the KGB and the tag.
And you're going back and forth with the time when he's like, I'm busy and you're like,
what's about 445?
我总是笑个不停，尤其是约翰和我，我们总是互相逗笑。我们只要看对方的眼睛就知道要笑场了。所以我记不清了，但我敢肯定，尤其是约翰做克格勃的那最后一部分，我肯定笑得流泪了，我们不得不切掉，你知道，至少十几次。我也，我的意思是，听着，这一集的首尾呼应是它以克格勃开始，以克格勃和标签结束。你来回争论，当他说我很忙，你说4点45分怎么样？
I was like, I know those guys were laughing.
Yeah.
I'm sure we can fit you in.
Yes, 515.
Oh, Rain, thank you so much for calling in and chatting with us. We love you. You are our most frequent guest on Office Ladies. That is your title. It belongs to you. And we love you, Rain. And we love you. We love your heart. We love, you know, you have such a heart for service, Rain. And I've always admired that about you. And we're just excited for folks to hear metaphysical milkshake. And I love it because then it's kind of like, you know, you're in my bathroom with me.
No, that's weird.
Like, I was listening as I got ready.
But you know what I mean.
我当时想，我知道那些家伙在笑。是的。我相信我们可以安排你。是的，5点15分。哦，雷恩，非常感谢你打电话来和我们聊天。我们爱你。你是《办公室女士》最频繁的嘉宾。那是你的头衔。它属于你。我们爱你，雷恩。我们也爱你。我们爱你的心。我们爱，你知道，你有一颗服务的心，雷恩。我一直很钦佩你这一点。我们只是很兴奋让大家听到《形而上学的奶昔》。我喜欢它，因为那样就像，你知道，你在我的浴室里陪我。不，那很奇怪。就像，我准备的时候在听。但你知道我的意思。
You guys are the best.
Congrats on the success of office ladies.
I hope it launches an Oprah-esque empire for the two of you.
Thank you.
We'll receive that.
We love you, Rain.
We'll talk to you soon.
Take care.
你们是最棒的。祝贺《办公室女士》的成功。我希望它能为你们俩开启一个奥普拉式的帝国。谢谢。我们会接受的。我们爱你，雷恩。我们很快再聊。保重。
I want to come to meet Alma.
Yes, come over and meet the peacock.
We will.
All right.
Bye.
Bye. I just love that fella.
I beyond love him.
我想去见阿尔玛。是的，过来见见孔雀。我们会去的。好的。再见。再见。再见。我就是喜欢那个家伙。我不仅仅是喜欢他。
I love him.
Rain, thank you so much for stopping by.
And now, lady, we got to get into this episode.
Let's do it.
You know, we've talked a little bit about this cold open already, but we haven't really broken it down.
So let's get into it.
Pam is on the phone.
She's trying to give someone like maybe a fax number.
我爱他。雷恩，非常感谢你过来。现在，女士们，我们得进入这一集了。开始吧。你知道，我们已经谈过一点这个冷开场了，但我们还没有真正拆解它。所以让我们开始吧。帕姆在打电话。她试图给某人一个传真号码。
I want to point out at 10 seconds, Nick is still in office all day.
In the note.
the post-it note. There's the same post-it note from last week. It's on the PINStar post-it paper. Nick in
office all day. He's still there, folks. So Michael's going to come over and he's messing with Pam.
She's trying to give this phone number and he's like five or nine, three, two, like trying to mess her up.
She hangs up and she's like, Michael, that makes us look so unprofessional. Yeah. Well, he can't wait.
He's been there because he has a really good knock-knock joke for her. That's right. Knock-knock.
Who's there?
我想指出在10秒处，尼克整天都在办公室。在便条里。那个便利贴。那是上周的同一张便利贴。它在PINStar便利贴纸上。尼克整天在办公室。他还在那儿，伙计们。所以迈克尔要过来了，他在捉弄帕姆。她试图给这个电话号码，他就像5或9，3，2，就像试图搞乱她。她挂断了电话，她说，迈克尔，这让我们看起来很不专业。是的。好吧，他等不及了。他一直在那儿，因为他有一个非常好的敲门笑话要讲给她听。没错。敲敲。谁在那儿？
Buddha. Buddha who? Buddha this bread for me. And then he sits a stick of butter. It's been in his hand. It's not even in the wrapper. I know. I'll have you know it was not scripted to be unwrapped. But on the day, we just thought that would be really funny. And originally my line in the script, when I look at the butter and the everything on my desk, I was supposed to say, you're making a mess. But I changed it to there's butter on my desk.
Yeah. And I thought that was like such a great little find in the moment when we were rehearsing.
It's very Pam, though. It's like people leave trash on your death.
All the time.
It's just a statement. It's like resignation.
It is. Now there's butter on my desk. Now there's butter on my desk. That's my day today.
Well, Dwight is super excited about this knock knock joke and he wants in on the fun.
He's got a great one.
佛陀。佛陀谁？佛陀（Butter）这块面包给我。然后他放下一块黄油。它一直在他手里。甚至没在包装纸里。我知道。我告诉你，剧本里没写要拆开包装。但在那一天，我们只是觉得那样会非常有趣。最初我在剧本里的台词，当我看着桌上的黄油和一切时，我应该说，你在制造混乱。但我把它改成了桌上有黄油。是的。我觉得那是我们在排练时即兴想到的一个很棒的小发现。这很帕姆，虽然。就像人们把垃圾留在你的桌子上。一直。这只是一个陈述。就像辞职。确实。现在桌上有黄油。现在桌上有黄油。这就是我今天的一天。好吧，德怀特对这个敲门笑话超级兴奋，他想参与其中。他有一个很棒的。
Yeah. And he's like, Michael, please. And Michael doesn't want to hear it. He's like, please.
And I just feel like we got to hear Dwight's one.
Knock Knock joke.
Let's do it.
No.
Okay.
Michael, please, please, please.
Please let me.
是的。他说，迈克尔，拜托。迈克尔不想听。他说，拜托。我只是觉得我们得听听德怀特的那个。敲门笑话。开始吧。不。好的。迈克尔，拜托，拜托，拜托。请让我讲。
All right.
Knock, knock.
Who's there?
KGB.
We ever asked the questions.
What the hell was that?
What are you doing?
好吧。敲敲。谁在那儿？克格勃。克格勃。我们问问题。那到底是什么？你在做什么？
Hey, hey.
Stop, bitch.
And they're just getting like the slapping fest.
And then Jim has to get in on it.
Yep.
Do we need to hear that one?
No more knock-knock jokes.
你在做什么？嘿，嘿。停下，混蛋。他们只是在进行扇耳光比赛。然后吉姆不得不参与进来。是的。我们需要听那个吗？没有更多的敲门笑话了。
That's it.
Ding don't.
Who's there?
KGB.
Do I get the door.
I'm not answering the door.
Dingo.
No way.
就是这样。叮咚。谁在那儿？克格勃。我去开门。我不开门。叮咚。没门。
It's the key.
Ding, no.
I'm not answering that.
Yes, you're going to answer it.
I'm not going to answer it.
It's the KGB.
The KGB will fit for no one.
It's true.
是钥匙。叮，不。我不开门。是的，你要开门。我不开门。是克格勃。克格勃不会为任何人开门。是真的。
And there's the it's true.
And there it is.
Well, now we're going to start the main plot of this episode.
Michael arrives to work dressed as Willie Wonka.
He's so excited.
He points out the jelly.
Beans? What are these? Pam's like jelly beans. She's like, no, they're extraordinary jelly
是真的。就是这样。好吧，现在我们要开始这一集的主线剧情了。迈克尔打扮成威利·旺卡来上班。他太兴奋了。他指着软糖。豆子？这些是什么？帕姆说是软糖豆。她说，不，它们是特别的软糖
beans. He's like so ready for his performance. And he shares that he's put this golden ticket 10% off
in different boxes of paper and someone's going to get it and their day is going to be full of
whimsy and excitement and fantasy. Here is what the golden ticket says. What? This whimsical promotion
saves you 10% off your total order with Dunder Miflin.
Scranton, Pennsylvania.
That's what it says.
This whimsical promotion.
In the conference room, Michael is just like already taking credit for his great idea.
豆。他准备好表演了。他分享说他把这张10%折扣的金奖券放进了不同的纸盒里，有人会得到它，他们的一天将充满奇思妙想、兴奋和幻想。这就是金奖券上写的。什么？这个异想天开的促销活动为您在邓德·米夫林的总订单节省10%。斯克兰顿，宾夕法尼亚州。这就是上面写的。这个异想天开的促销活动。在会议室里，迈克尔就像已经把功劳归于他的好点子了。
It's such a great idea.
He needs everyone to come in the conference room and talk about how we need more good ideas like this one.
He says, and this is like something like people that do this crack me up, he goes, it might be the best
idea ever in like the history of ideas.
You're like, okay, buddy.
Here's what I don't understand. He's written on a board, marketing, greatness, Michael. I didn't get it. It was very amusing to me. Well, his job is to prophylagate great ideas. I guess so. He really wants the group, though, to tell them their golden ticket idea. He knows his golden ticket. A golden ticket. Yeah. Jim's like, well, we could rent out our trucks. He's like, no, post-it notes, right? Golden ticket. NASA, lots of gold.
ticket ideas there.
Andy's going to say golden girls and a few other things.
这是一个如此棒的点子。他需要每个人都进会议室，谈谈我们需要更多像这样的好点子。他说，这就像那些做这种事的人让我很着迷，他说，这可能是历史上最好的点子。你就像，好吧，伙计。我不明白的是。他在板上写了，营销，伟大，迈克尔。我不明白。这对我来说非常有趣。好吧，他的工作是传播伟大的点子。我想是吧。但他确实希望团队告诉他他们的金奖券点子。他知道他的金奖券。金奖券。是的。吉姆说，好吧，我们可以出租我们的卡车。他说，不，便利贴，对吧？金奖券。NASA，有很多金奖券点子。安迪要说黄金女郎和其他一些东西。
That start with the word golden.
That start with golden grams.
Look over his shoulder.
Angela Martin, one minute, 59 seconds.
Major eye roll at Andy.
Angela, I roll.
Yeah.
She thinks Andy's an idiot, guys.
以“金”字开头的。以金格雷厄姆开头。看他的肩膀。安吉拉·马丁，1分59秒。对安迪翻了个大白眼。安吉拉，翻白眼。是的。她认为安迪是个白痴，伙计们。
She was only engaged to him just two seconds ago, but she's over it.
Well, now we're going to move to the kitchen.
Andy and Kevin are at the table.
Pam and Jim are over by the counter. And Kevin really wants to ask out Lynn. And he's just getting a lot of
advice from these guys, conflicting advice. I have two background catches that just delighted me.
Oh. All right. Number one, these guys are both eating donuts. I noticed that, and I swear to God,
those are the donuts we got every morning because Kevin's donut is my donut. The Sprinkles Donuts.
Yes. And Andy had the powdered sugar.
她两秒钟前才和他订婚，但她已经受够了。好吧，现在我们要去厨房了。安迪和凯文在桌子旁。帕姆和吉姆在柜台边。凯文真的很想约林出去。他只是从这些人那里得到了很多建议，相互矛盾的建议。我有两个背景捕捉，让我很高兴。哦。好吧。第一，这些人都在吃甜甜圈。我注意到了，我发誓，那些是我们每天早上拿到的甜甜圈，因为凯文的甜甜圈就是我的甜甜圈。洒糖甜甜圈。是的。安迪有糖粉的。
Okay, background catch number two. I love it when our show does this when it takes an object from a prior episode and pops it back into a new one. Ready?
Four minutes. I think I saw it too. Kevin's coffee mug. Yep. Kevin's coffee mug is the same mug that Kelly gave to him at her customer survey party. You know, everyone's face in the big star. But what about Andy's mug?
Andy's mug is the same one from Moroccan Christmas
and it was featured in a deleted scene I talked about
when Jim and Pam decide to shop within the office
for Christmas for each other because they're so broke
Jim goes up to Andy and asks him about his mug
and it's in the bloopers.
好的，背景捕捉二。我喜欢我们的剧集这样做，当它从之前的剧集中拿走一个物体并把它放进一个新的剧集中时。准备好了吗？四分钟。我想我也看到了。凯文的咖啡杯。是的。凯文的咖啡杯和凯莉在她的客户调查派对上给他的杯子是一样的。你知道，大明星上每个人的脸。但安迪的杯子呢？安迪的杯子和《摩洛哥圣诞节》里的是同一个，它出现在我谈到的一个删除场景中，当时吉姆和帕姆决定在办公室里为彼此买圣诞礼物，因为他们太穷了，吉姆走到安迪面前问他关于他的杯子，这在花絮里。
It was also in the script.
Two coffee mugs from two prior episodes.
I love that.
Well, later in this episode, if you look at Oscars' desk,
he's going to have his America's Got Talent mug too.
Oh, love it.
Well, this whole Kevin and Andy and Jim and Pam's storyline was much bigger in the actual shooting draft.
And there are a few deleted scenes and things I want to share.
它也在剧本里。两个来自之前剧集的咖啡杯。我喜欢那个。好吧，在这一集后面，如果你看奥斯卡的桌子，他也会有他的《美国达人》杯子。哦，喜欢它。好吧，整个凯文、安迪、吉姆和帕姆的故事线在实际拍摄草稿中要大得多。有一些删除的场景和我想分享的事情。
First of all, this is the scene that would have set up this whole storyline.
It's at the beginning of the day and they're getting in the elevator.
Kevin, Jim and Pam, and who rushes in at the last minute because she works in the Scranton
Business Park.
But Lynn, can we hear it?
Hold on the eyes, please.
Hi, Kevin.
Hey, Lynn.
首先，这是会引出整个故事线的场景。是在一天开始时，他们正在进电梯。凯文、吉姆和帕姆，谁在最后一分钟冲了进来，因为她在斯克兰顿商业园工作。但是林，我们能听听吗？等一下，请看眼睛。嗨，凯文。嘿，林。
Did you get my message?
Um, yeah.
I've been really busy.
Oh.
It's okay.
Yeah, I'm probably going to be busy for the next 20 days or so.
So, yeah.
Bye.
你收到我的留言了吗？嗯，是的。我一直很忙。哦。没关系。是的，我可能在接下来的20天左右都很忙。所以，是的。再见。
You're going to be busy for the next 20 days or so.
I thought you liked Lynn.
I do like Lynn.
That's what Andy told me to say.
Uh-huh.
Right? So Jim and Pam are learning that Andy has been giving Kevin some pretty bad advice.
Yeah. He likes Lynn, but tells her, you know, he didn't return her messages and he's going to be busy for 20 days.
Wow. That's amazing. Jim and Pam can't let Andy do this to Kevin. So they start giving him advice, right? Just ask her out. And in the deleted scenes, you really get a sneak peek into where Andy's brain is at. You got to
你接下来的20天左右都很忙。我以为你喜欢林。我确实喜欢林。那是安迪告诉我要说的。嗯哼。对吧？所以吉姆和帕姆正在了解到安迪一直在给凯文一些非常糟糕的建议。是的。他喜欢林，但告诉她，你知道，他没回她的信息，而且他接下来的20天都很忙。哇。那太神奇了。吉姆和帕姆不能让安迪对凯文这样做。所以他们开始给他建议，对吧？直接约她出去。在删除的场景中，你真的可以一窥安迪的大脑在想什么。你必须
to hear this talking head. I was raised to be a gentleman around women, but when your fiance
is Satan, that doesn't work. So I have some new ideas and new techniques, and I'm trying
them out. Kevin Malone is my guinea pig. Oh, man, I wish that had stayed in. Doesn't that explain
at all? It does. I mean, I think I was able to realize that the reason that Andy is being this way is
because he's still reeling from his breakup with Angela,
but that really would have been great.
I know, because, I mean, I don't think Andy's a bad guy,
but he's clearly hurt and acting out and using poor Kevin.
听听这个采访。我从小就被教育要在女性面前做一个绅士，但当你的未婚妻是撒旦时，那就不管用了。所以我有一些新的点子和技巧，我正在尝试。凯文·马龙是我的小白鼠。哦，天哪，我希望那段保留下来。那不是解释了一切吗？确实。我的意思是，我想我能够意识到安迪之所以这样是因为他仍然沉浸在与安吉拉的分手中，但那真的会很棒。我知道，因为，我的意思是，我不认为安迪是个坏人，但他显然受伤了，在发泄，并利用可怜的凯文。
Well, listen, Jim's going to get a phone call now.
Guess what?
What?
His client, Tom, has found a golden ticket.
Tom from Blue Cross of Pennsylvania.
Our biggest client.
Uh-oh.
Oscar, how much is that going to cost us?
好吧，听着，吉姆现在要接个电话了。猜猜怎么着？什么？他的客户汤姆发现了一张金奖券。来自宾夕法尼亚蓝十字的汤姆。我们最大的客户。哦哦。奥斯卡，那会让我们损失多少钱？
Michael wants to know. It's going to hurt a bit. Well, what about this? Guys, Tom found all five golden tickets.
Holy moly. Did they say one per customer? Nope. Nope. Our biggest client just got 50% off their total order with us.
I mean, this is a huge win. Talk about winning the golden ticket. He won all the golden tickets. He won all of them.
This made me think, Jenna, have you ever won? Have you ever won?
like a really big ticket item? I don't think so. I called my mom because I know my aunt Ann
has won things. Like she signs up for, you know, raffles and things. And she's won trips.
Really? Yeah, she's super lucky. And I was like, mom, doesn't Aunt Anne win a lot of things? And she said,
well, you know, your dad won a very big ticket item. What did your dad win? And I was like,
迈克尔想知道。那会有点疼。好吧，这个呢？伙计们，汤姆发现了所有五张金奖券。天哪。他们说每位客户一张吗？没有。没有。我们最大的客户刚刚在我们的总订单中获得了50%的折扣。我的意思是，这是一个巨大的胜利。谈谈赢得金奖券。他赢得了所有的金奖券。他赢得了所有。这让我想到，珍娜，你赢过吗？你赢过吗？比如一个非常大的奖品？我不这么认为。我给我妈打了电话，因为我知道我安姨赢过东西。比如她报名参加，你知道，抽奖之类的。她赢过旅行。真的？是的，她超级幸运。我说，妈，安姨不是赢了很多东西吗？她说，嗯，你知道，你爸赢过一个非常大的奖品。你爸赢了什么？我说，
mom, what are you talking about? And she said, well, this was before you were born. And Jenna,
this story just delighted me so much. One, because, you know, my dad's passed away. And so any new
information, because you know, you play every memory, you look at everything, but anything that you
hear about someone you loved who's no longer with you, you just, oh, it's like this beautiful,
wonderful thing. So my mom said, oh yeah, before you were born, we had just moved to Lafayette, Louisiana,
and the school was having a fundraiser, and they were raffling off a brand new,
pink station wagon. What? She said it had a cream white top and your dad went and donated some money
and signed up and he won the car. Your dad won a pink station wagon? Yes. And she said and it was a very
妈，你在说什么？她说，嗯，那是在你出生之前。珍娜，这个故事让我太高兴了。第一，因为，你知道，我爸去世了。所以任何新的信息，因为你知道，你重温每一个记忆，你看每一件事，但任何你听到的关于你爱过但不再和你在一起的人的事情，你只是，哦，这就像这个美丽、美妙的事情。所以我妈说，哦是的，在你出生之前，我们刚搬到路易斯安那州的拉斐特，学校正在举行筹款活动，他们正在抽奖一辆全新的粉色旅行车。什么？她说它有一个奶油白色的车顶，你爸去捐了一些钱，报名参加，然后他赢了那辆车。你爸赢了一辆粉色旅行车？是的。她说那是一辆非常
good car and we drove it for a long time. Do any of your sisters remember this car? I was like,
my sister Billy said she remembers it. But I was like, oh my goodness. And my mom's like, I know we have a
picture somewhere. I said, mom, please. And I have.
I have to see it.
And she said, oh, Ange, your dad was so tickled that he won that car.
He was so excited.
And she said, and it was a light pink with a cream top.
And they drove it around for years.
好的车，我们开了很长时间。你的姐妹们记得这辆车吗？我说，我姐姐比利说她记得。但我说，哦天哪。我妈说，我知道我们有张照片在某处。我说，妈，拜托。我必须看到它。她说，哦，安吉，你爸赢了那辆车真是太高兴了。他太兴奋了。她说，那是浅粉色配奶油色车顶。他们开了好几年。
I love that story.
I know.
It made my day.
You know, I have been pitching for years, a documentary series that I call Little Winners.
And it is all about people who,
have won, not the lottery, but raffles, and they get something like this car or like a new recliner
or like a trip, right? And how did it affect their life? Little winners. No one will buy it from me.
No one wants to make it. I pitch it all the time. I will no one make little winners. I love little
我喜欢那个故事。我知道。这让我的一天都很美好。你知道，我多年来一直在推销一个我称之为“小赢家”的纪录片系列。它是关于那些赢了，不是彩票，而是抽奖的人，他们得到了像这辆车或像一把新躺椅或像一次旅行之类的东西，对吧？这如何影响了他们的生活？小赢家。没人会从我这里买。没人想做它。我一直在推销它。我不会有人做小赢家。我喜欢小
winners. We could do it as a podcast and have the winner on. They could tell us all about it. Here's the thing.
You know, I like to think about my parents. They were young parents. They had three young girls at this time and what that car meant to them. And then I also think about the car dealer there in Lafayette, Louisiana and how the school, probably the superintendent, was buddies with the guy at the dealership and was like, what do you got that we can raffle off? And he's like, well, that pink station wagon, no one wanted. We can't sell it. It's a right off. I'll give it to you.
Okay. Amazing. Amazing. So Michael is spiraling out, though, because he's realizing Blue Cross from Pennsylvania getting this many golden tickets, he's going to get fired. And Jim is upset, too, because that's his commission. Oh, right. Right? So Michael is going to storm down to the warehouse. I love the beginning of this scene. This scene is brilliant. He goes barreling in going, hey, hey, hey, you idiot to Daryl. And Daryl says, start over.
So good. I was like, I'm keeping that. I am keeping that. The next time one of the kids has a moment
where they're sassing me, I'm going to be like, start over. Exactly. And then Michael comes back with,
Sir, that was all in the script. I looked that up. So did I. So did I. Michael's like, Daryl,
how could this happen? How could this happen? And he says, I put three pallets on the truck for Blue Cross
every week. Where were you putting the boxes? Were they near each other? And Michael's like,
赢家。我们可以把它做成播客，让赢家上来。他们可以告诉我们所有关于它的事情。问题是这样的。你知道，我喜欢想起我的父母。他们是年轻的父母。那时他们有三个年幼的女儿，那辆车对他们意味着什么。然后我也想到了路易斯安那州拉斐特的那个汽车经销商，学校，可能是校长，和那个经销商是哥们，就说，你有什么可以拿来抽奖的吗？他说，嗯，那辆粉红色的旅行车，没人要。我们卖不掉。那是注销资产。我给你吧。好的。太棒了。太棒了。但是迈克尔陷入了混乱，因为他意识到蓝十字保险公司从宾夕法尼亚州得到了这么多金奖券，他会被解雇的。吉姆也很生气，因为那是他的佣金。哦，对。对吧？所以迈克尔要冲到仓库去。我喜欢这个场景的开头。这个场景太精彩了。他横冲直撞地进去，对达里尔说，嘿，嘿，嘿，你这个白痴。达里尔说，重来。太棒了。我当时想，我要记住这个。我要记住这个。下次孩子们有对我无礼的时候，我就要说，重来。没错。然后迈克尔回了一句，先生，那都是剧本里的。我查过了。我也查过了。我也查过了。迈克尔说，达里尔，这怎么可能发生？这怎么可能发生？他说，我每周给蓝十字放三个托盘到卡车上。你把箱子放在哪里了？它们挨在一起吗？迈克尔说，
I need to ask you something. I need you to be honest with me. What is a palate?
So good. So good. David Wallace is not happy. He calls. Pam takes the call. But Michael is sort of sneaking out of his office. He's taken off his Willy Wonka outfit. Yeah, he's getting rid of the evidence.
Yes. He's like, do not. I am not here. I am not here. So Pam has to say that he's at a civil rights rally at the Lincoln Memorial.
Which I want to point out is in Washington.
Yeah, he's gone to Washington, D.C., I guess.
And the same day, he's going to go to a civil rights movement in Washington, D.C., and get a colonoscopy in Scranton.
Exactly.
Well, Michael tosses his Willy Wonka costume into a dumpster.
我需要问你一件事。我需要你对我诚实。什么是托盘（palate）？太棒了。太棒了。大卫·华莱士很不高兴。他打电话来。帕姆接了电话。但迈克尔正偷偷溜出办公室。他脱掉了他的威利·旺卡服装。是的，他正在销毁证据。是的。他说，不要。我不在。我不在。所以帕姆不得不说他在林肯纪念堂参加民权集会。我想指出那是在华盛顿。是的，我想他去华盛顿特区了。同一天，他要去华盛顿特区参加民权运动，还要在斯克兰顿做结肠镜检查。没错。好吧，迈克尔把他的威利·旺卡服装扔进了垃圾桶。
He's now wearing a Pioneer's football shirt, and I had to look this up.
This is a minor league football team from Wilkesbury Scranton that played in the AF2,
and they had a really strong season in 2009 when we shot this episode.
It's kind of like perfect that he's wearing this shirt because they only ended up losing two of their games that year.
They made it to the playoffs.
Then they made it all the way to the Arena Cup, which is like the Super Bowl of AF2 football.
They ended up losing, but it was like a great, great season for them.
They were kind of on a roll.
他现在穿着一件先锋队的足球衫，我不得不查了一下。这是来自威尔克斯-巴里/斯克兰顿的一支小联盟足球队，在AF2联赛中比赛，我们在拍摄这一集时，他们在2009年有一个非常强劲的赛季。他穿这件衬衫真是太完美了，因为他们那一年最终只输了两场比赛。他们打进了季后赛。然后他们一路打进了竞技场杯，就像AF2足球的超级碗一样。他们最终输了，但对他们来说这是一个非常非常棒的赛季。他们当时势头正猛。
Their previous season had been good as well.
I love it.
I love every time we have these local references on the show in ways that don't even get mentioned.
Right.
We never even mention this shirt, but there it is, just creating specificity.
I love it.
Michael's going to make an announcement, everyone to the conference room.
He's a lot of announcements in this episode, a lot of announcements.
他们之前的赛季也很好。我喜欢它。我喜欢我们节目中每次出现这些本地参考资料的方式，甚至都没有被提及。对吧。我们甚至从来没有提到过这件衬衫，但它就在那里，只是创造了具体性。我喜欢它。迈克尔要宣布一件事，大家到会议室来。他在这一集里宣布了很多事情，很多公告。
He's really, I think, just trying to find a way out.
He says he has a big net where he takes all of their subconscious ideas.
and tries to turn them into something.
And Michael's like, guys, guys, they're not going to fire us.
We're fine.
And Oscar's like, what do you call shutting down a branch?
And then Michael says, someone needs to come up with a golden ticket idea to get them out of this mess.
Mm-hmm.
我想他真的只是在想办法脱身。他说他有一个大网，他把他们所有的潜意识想法都收集起来，试图把它们变成某种东西。迈克尔说，伙计们，伙计们，他们不会解雇我们的。我们很好。奥斯卡说，你管关闭一个分公司叫什么？然后迈克尔说，有人需要想出一个金奖券的主意来让他们摆脱这个烂摊子。嗯哼。
You know?
And Pam says, do you mean an idea that blows up in our faces later?
Oh.
That kind of idea.
That's some Pam sass.
That is some Pam sass.
So while Michael's up at the top of the conference room, he's wearing a suit jacket.
Mm-hmm.
你知道吗？帕姆说，你是说一个以后会让我们自食其果的主意吗？哦。那种主意。那是帕姆的讽刺。那是帕姆的讽刺。所以当迈克尔在会议室前面时，他穿着西装外套。嗯哼。
And I'm thinking, where did that come from?
Because the last time we saw him, he was at the dumpster in his Pioneer's football shirt.
Right.
I looked it up.
It's Andy's jacket.
He's wearing Andy's jacket.
And there was a bit at the top of this scene that got cut, where as they're entering the room, Michael says, Andy, give me your jacket.
You can do something for me.
我在想，那是从哪儿来的？因为我们上次见到他时，他穿着先锋队的足球衫在垃圾桶旁。对吧。我查了一下。那是安迪的外套。他穿着安迪的外套。在这个场景的开头有一段被剪掉了，当他们进入房间时，迈克尔说，安迪，把你的外套给我。你可以为我做点事。
I want your jacket.
So that is why he's now wearing this odd jacket over his football shirt.
Well, he's got to still look like the boss.
The phone's going to ring now.
Not good.
It's David Wallace.
Pam says Michael's having a colonoscopy.
I'm not sure that David Wallace believes it.
我想要你的外套。所以这就是为什么他现在在足球衫外面穿着这件奇怪的外套。好吧，他还得看起来像个老板。电话要响了。不好。是大卫·华莱士。帕姆说迈克尔正在做结肠镜检查。我不确定大卫·华莱士是否相信。
You think?
Because he was just in Washington.
Michael gets on the phone with him and literally is reading off the procedure of how you give a colonoscopy off his computer.
It's pretty amazing.
But now it is clear.
David Wallace says the company is going to lose a lot of money.
How did you let this happen?
Whose idea was it?
你觉得呢？因为他刚才还在华盛顿。迈克尔接了他的电话，字面上是在从他的电脑上读出如何进行结肠镜检查的程序。这太神奇了。但现在很清楚了。大卫·华莱士说公司要损失很多钱。你怎么能让这种事发生？是谁的主意？
Someone's got to pay for this terrible idea.
Michael tells David Wallace it was Dwight.
Just so devious.
I know.
Oh, Michael.
It's like David Wallace is just naming people.
And he says, was it Dwight?
And Michael's like, yes.
总得有人为这个糟糕的主意付出代价。迈克尔告诉大卫·华莱士那是德怀特的主意。真是太阴险了。我知道。哦，迈克尔。就像大卫·华莱士只是在点名。他说，是德怀特吗？迈克尔说，是的。
Well, now Michael has got to convince Dwight to take the fall for him.
And so he's going to get out his.
diary and he's going to say Dwight, I wrote it down that it was your idea. He tries to convince
Dwight that Dwight is remembering wrong. What happened this morning? Now, you know, Dwight runs to
get his diary. It's like the dueling diaries where they're going back and forth. Michael realizes
he's not making any headway with this whole diary business. So he says, would you like to go out to
lunch with me, just the two of us? And Dwight says, with all my heart, this scene continues in the
script, Jenna. So after Dwight says, with all my heart, he says, but I already ate lunch. And Michael
好吧，现在迈克尔必须说服德怀特为他背黑锅。所以他要拿出他的日记，他要说德怀特，我写下来了，那是你的主意。他试图说服德怀特，德怀特记错了。今天早上发生了什么？现在，你知道，德怀特跑去拿他的日记。就像决斗日记一样，他们来回争论。迈克尔意识到他在整个日记的事情上没有任何进展。所以他说，你想和我一起去吃午饭吗，就我们两个？德怀特说，全心全意，这个场景在剧本里还在继续，珍娜。所以德怀特说全心全意之后，他说，但我已经吃过午饭了。迈克尔
says, it's 11 a.m. Dwight says, as a farmer, I eat breakfast at 4.30. At 10, I'm famished for lunch.
If you wait three hours, we can have supper. Maybe. Michael says, no, no, no. How about we do something
else you like? Jenna, did you notice there are no scenes of them at the restaurant? They're supposedly
going to have lunch, right? Because in the episode, Michael says, go have lunch.
I don't know that Dwight's already eaten.
All of that's been cut out.
Right.
And then the remainder of their scenes, they're on the side of the road.
说，现在才上午11点。德怀特说，作为一个农民，我4点半吃早餐。10点，我饿得想吃午饭。如果你等三个小时，我们可以吃晚餐。也许吧。迈克尔说，不，不，不。我们做点你喜欢的其他事情怎么样？珍娜，你注意到没有他们在餐馆的场景吗？他们本应该去吃午饭，对吧？因为在这一集里，迈克尔说，去吃午饭吧。我不知道德怀特已经吃过了。所有这些都被剪掉了。对吧。然后他们剩下的场景，他们就在路边。
They're taking a walk.
Well, here is a scene that was in the deleted scenes that I just love so much.
Of all the things that Dwight would want to do, guess what he loves to do?
Go for walks?
Oh, lady, no.
He likes a stroll.
Are you still taking those strolls that you like to take?
Thrice weekly.
他们在散步。好吧，这是一个被删减的场景，我非常喜欢。在德怀特想做的所有事情中，猜猜他最喜欢做什么？去散步？哦，天哪，不。他喜欢漫步（stroll）。你还在进行那些你喜欢的漫步吗？每周三次。
Okay, let's go take a stroll together.
I thought you said my strolls were silly.
No, just because you can't call them walks.
You really want a stroll?
Yes.
Do you want a power stroll or just a regular stroll?
You call it.
Power stroll.
好吧，我们一起去漫步吧。我以为你说我的漫步很傻。不，只是因为你不能叫它们散步。你真的想漫步吗？是的。你想要动力漫步还是普通的漫步？你说了算。动力漫步。
You wearing sunblock?
Yes.
What SPF?
One?
That's like water.
I'll grab my tube.
Okay.
Oh.
你涂防晒霜了吗？是的。什么SPF？1？那就像水一样。我去拿我的管子。好的。哦。
He loves a stroll.
Clearly it's like a whole thing with him and Michael about calling it a stroll or a walk.
Then there's another scene.
where they're down in the lobby and Hank is there.
And Dwight is putting sunscreen on Michael's face.
And Hank looks up and Deadpan says,
you found somebody to go on a stroll.
And Dwight goes, I did.
他喜欢漫步。显然，他和迈克尔之间关于称之为漫步还是散步是一件大事。然后还有另一个场景。他们在大厅里，汉克在那里。德怀特正在给迈克尔的脸上涂防晒霜。汉克抬头面无表情地说，你找到人去漫步了。德怀特说，我找到了。
And Hank goes, nice.
This is amazing because we got a ton of mail
because people were pointing out Dwight's shoes in the scene
when he is walking, aka strolling with Michael,
tons of people said,
why does Dwight have on very white, very non-Dwight trainers?
Like, where did these come from?
And I looked in the script and it says,
汉克说，不错。这太神奇了，因为我们收到了大量的邮件，因为人们指出德怀特在走路，也就是和迈克尔漫步时的鞋子，很多人说，为什么德怀特穿着非常白、非常不像德怀特的运动鞋？就像，这些是从哪儿来的？我在剧本里查了一下，上面写着，
Michael and Dwight are walking.
Dwight is wearing sneakers and walks with his hands clasped behind his back.
That was like a script note,
but I'm sure it was all based on this backstory that Dwight strolls three times a week.
He's got his sunblock, he's got his shoes.
He probably has a little bag.
he takes to work, clearly Hank knows how much Dwight loves a stroll and how he's been looking for
a stroll buddy. I love it. I love it. I know it tickled me. Well, this stroll is not going to
迈克尔和德怀特在走路。德怀特穿着运动鞋，双手背在身后走路。那就像一个剧本注释，但我敢肯定这一切都是基于德怀特每周漫步三次的背景故事。他有防晒霜，他有鞋子。他可能有一个小包，他带去上班，显然汉克知道德怀特有多喜欢漫步，以及他一直在寻找一个漫步伙伴。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。我知道这让我很开心。好吧，这次漫步不会
convince Dwight. Dwight says, I am not going to fall on my sword for you. It's not going to happen.
He's done it before. He's fallen on his sword, and it wasn't pleasant. It wasn't. Michael makes a
pretty big speech to Dwight. He's like, listen, why would you want to stay here? Yeah. You're cooped up.
You're not even dating Angela anymore. You have a whole whole.
farm. Yeah. And he says, you know, on the other hand, I would be lost without Dundermifflin.
And Dwight says, what about Shulala, Michael? This is a Mindy Kailing thing, for sure. This has
Mindy Kaling written all over it. And then Michael has a talking head where he says, I have an idea
for a fancy men's shoe store called Shulala. And it's just men's shoes for the special occasions in a
说服德怀特。德怀特说，我不会为你背黑锅的。这不会发生的。他以前做过。他背过黑锅，那并不愉快。确实不愉快。迈克尔对德怀特发表了一番长篇大论。他说，听着，你为什么想留在这里？是的。你被关在这里。你甚至不再和安吉拉约会了。你有一个完整的农场。是的。他说，你知道，另一方面，没有邓德·米夫林我会迷失方向。德怀特说，那舒拉拉（Shulala）呢，迈克尔？这绝对是明迪·卡灵的主意。这上面写满了明迪·卡灵的名字。然后迈克尔有一个谈话头，他说，我有一个关于一家高档男鞋店的主意，叫舒拉拉。它只是为男人生命中的特殊场合准备的男鞋，比如你结婚的那天，或者你妻子生孩子的那天，或者只是在家里休息时穿的。是的。好吧，我们收到了凯拉·G的来信，她说，我只是想让你们女士们知道，迈克尔似乎已经在不列颠哥伦比亚省的纳尔逊把舒拉拉开起来了。哦。我查了一下，果然，有一个舒拉拉。根据他们的网站，他们是一家精品鞋店，提供来自世界各地的精致皮革、鞋类和手袋。他们是一家自1983年以来就存在的家族企业。好吧，我想让你们知道，路易斯安那州拉斐特有一个舒拉拉。我也看到了。
man's life, like the day that you get married or the day your wife has a baby or just for
lounging around the house. Yeah. Well, we got some mail from Kayla G. who said, I just want to let you
ladies know that Michael seems to have gotten shoe la-la up and running in Nelson British Columbia.
Oh. And I looked it up and sure enough, there is a shoe la-law. According to their website,
they are a boutique shoe store offering exquisite leather, footwear, and handbags from all over
the world. They are a family-run business that has been around since 1983.
Well, I want you guys to know that there is a shoe la lafayette, Louisiana.
I saw that too.
我出生的城镇。拉斐特，你知道吗？我喜欢他们鞋店的口号。如果你去他们的网站，那是一家服装精品店和鞋店。但他们的口号是，生命苦短，买该死的鞋子。这太棒了。所以有两个舒拉拉，迈克尔，但似乎都没有卖男鞋。哦，好吧，我非常希望迈克尔能拥有舒拉拉。
My town where I was born.
Lafayette, and you know what?
I love the slogan for their shoe store.
If you go on their website, it's a clothing boutique and shoes.
But their slogan is, life is short by the damn shoes.
That is amazing.
So there are two shoe la-laws, Michael, but none of them seem to sell men's shoes.
Oh, well, I would love nothing more for Michael to have Shulala.
好吧，我们有一个很棒的反向谈话头。是的，我注意到了。所以德怀特坐在迈克尔的椅子上，你拉开镜头露出迈克尔栖息在他身后。基本上在这个谈话头里，迈克尔说，他会为我做的。他会做的。他会背黑锅的。德怀特说，不，我还没决定。好吧，办公室里的人开始察觉到了。
Well, we have a great reverse talking head.
Yes, I noticed.
So Dwight is in Michael's chair and you pull back to reveal Michael perched behind him.
Basically in this talking head, Michael's like, he's going to do it for me.
He's going to do it.
He's going to take the fall.
And Dwight's like, no, I haven't decided.
Well, folks in the office are starting to catch on.
他们明白了。他们知道迈克尔在做什么。他想让德怀特背黑锅，他们开始议论这件事。你们伙计们，厨房里有一个被删减的场景，梅雷迪思、凯利、安吉拉和奥斯卡都在聊天，迈克尔走进来无意中听到了一点。他在浴室里监视他们。让我们听听。女士们。真的吗？我希望德怀特被解雇，我们能换个火辣的新人来代替他。
They get it.
They know what Michael's doing.
He wants Dwight to take the fall, and they start gossiping about it.
There's a scene in the kitchen, you guys, that was deleted, where Meredith, Kelly, and Angela, and Oscar are all being real chatty, and Michael walks in and overhears a bit.
And he's spying on them from the bathroom. Let's hear it.
Ladies.
Really?
I hope Dwight gets fired, and we get a hot new guy to replace them.
真的吗？如果是个火辣的新女孩呢？哦，天哪，我没想到这一点。我觉得迈克尔做的事情太可怕了。真的吗？我的意思是，这是不可接受的。嘿，你有没有注意到我们的浴室就在我们的厨房旁边？这怎么符合规范？
Seriously?
What if it's a hot new girl?
Oh my God, I had not thought of them.
I think it's horrible what Michael is doing.
Really?
I mean, this is unacceptable.
Hey, did you ever notice that our bathroom is right next to our kitchen?
How's that up to code?
我不知道。他对德怀特做的事情不公平。你当然会这么想。你以前和我有过关系。我认为男人和女人有关系。我讨厌我纠正这一点。我只是说德怀特不能为此承担责任。它必须落在迈克尔身上。
I don't know.
This is not fair what he's doing to Dwight.
Of course you think that.
You used to bone and I.
I think men bone women.
I hate that I'm correcting that.
All I'm saying is that Dwight can't take the blame for this.
It has to land on Michael.
是时候清算了。真的。好吧。这些就是我非常喜欢的那种生活片段。生活片段。生活片段。你又把它带回来了。这些就是我非常喜欢的那种办公室生活片段。只是闲聊。发生了很多事情。只是八卦和观点。嗯哼。你知道吗？我喜欢这个场景。迈克尔无意中听到了，伙计们。有一个完整的场景，迈克尔与每个人对质。他真的真的让他们说了出来。他冲进牛栏，说，嘿，大家，我需要宣布一件事。吉姆说，这是一个新的记录。迈克尔说，那是因为我今天有很多话要说，詹姆斯。嗯哼。他很生气。然后他绕着房间走，他对着房间大喊，你们有没有想过如果我被解雇会是什么样子？每个人都超级高兴地举起了手。迈克尔说，该死。我没要求举手。如果我被解雇，公司引进了新的领导层，你们根本不知道谁会来。
It's time for a reckoning.
True. Okay. These are the kind of slice of life. Slice o life. Slice oh life. You brought it back. These are the kind of slice of life office moments that I love so much. Just the scuttlebutt. There's so much going on. Just the gossip and the opinions. Uh-huh. You know? I loved this scene. And Michael overhears it, you guys. And there's a whole scene where Michael confronts everyone. And he really.
really lets him have it. He goes barging into the bullpen and he's like, hey, everyone, I need to make an
announcement. And Jim is like, this is a new record. And Michael goes, that's because I have a lot to say
today, James. Uh-huh. He's ticked off. And then he goes around the room and he's like,
yells to the room, have you wondered what it would be like if I was fired? And everyone super happy
raises their hand. And Michael's like, damn it. I didn't ask for a show of hands. If I
I get fired and corporate brings in new leadership, you have no idea who might come.
然后他开始挑出人来。他说，你们根本不知道情况会变得多糟。也许会是一个知道我们实际上不需要三个会计师的人。我现在记得拍摄这个场景了。是的，它在被删减的场景里。然后他直视吉姆和帕姆，他说，或者让情侣们一起工作而不把他们送到不同的分公司。然后他有这一刻，可能让我笑了。他说，所以，你们没想过那个，对吧？所以当我们假装在浴室里拉屎时，让我们咬住舌头，而不是说我的坏话，好吗？但那是一段很长的演讲，他真的让他们都说了出来。我非常喜欢这一集。我觉得史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在这一集里真是太棒了。他扮演了这么多不同的东西。我们已经和雷恩谈过这个了，但我绝对喜欢迈克尔和德怀特的动态。我真的很喜欢这一集。我也喜欢。这就像我们很久没见过的那些冷门剧集之一。我们当时想，哦，天哪，金奖券。我同意。金奖券就是金奖券。好吧，现在大卫·华莱士要出现了。他从纽约开车过来，伙计们。是的。大卫·华莱士到达办公室，对吧？
And then he starts singling people out.
He says, you have no idea how bad it could get.
Maybe it would be someone who knows that we don't actually need three accountants.
I remember shooting this scene now.
Yes, it's in the deleted scenes.
Then he looks right at Jim and Pam and he says,
or lets couples work together without sending them to different branches.
And then he has this moment and may be.
这是一件严肃的事情。是的。他和德怀特一起走进迈克尔的办公室。你可以听到针掉在地上的声音。他转向德怀特说，德怀特，我欠你一个道歉。蓝十字对金奖券促销活动非常兴奋，他们已经让邓德·米夫林成为他们所有办公用品的独家供应商。巨大！这太巨大了！他伸出手去和德怀特握手。
me laugh. He goes, so, you didn't think about that, huh? So let's just bite our tongues instead of
saying mean things about me when I pretend to be pooping in the bathroom, okay? But it was a long
speech and he really just lets them all have it. I love this episode so much. I think Steve Correll
just is brilliant in this episode. He's playing so many different things. We already talked about
this with rain, but I just absolutely love the Michael Dwight dynamic. I really loved this one.
I did too. This was like one of those sleeper ones that we hadn't seen in forever. And we're like,
oh my gosh, golden ticket. I agree. Golden ticket is a golden ticket. Well, now David Wallace is going to
show up. He drove from New York, you guys. Yeah. David Wallace arrives at the office, right?
迈克尔快要分裂了。他看着德怀特，好像在说，你最好让他知道那是我的主意！德怀特和他握了握手。说，谢谢你，大卫。现在所有的权力都颠倒了。令人惊叹，令人惊叹的写作。他们走到牛栏里。
This is a serious thing. Yeah. He goes into Michael's office with Dwight. You could hear a pin drop.
And he turns to Dwight and he says,
Dwight, I owe you an apology.
Blue Cross was so excited about the golden ticket promotion
that they have made Dunder Mifflin,
their exclusive provider for all office supplies.
Huge! This is huge!
And he puts his hand out to shake Dwight's hand.
华莱士告诉了所有人。德怀特获得了这次胜利。帕姆拥抱了他。我喜欢那样做。我喜欢它。然后克里德说，干得好，孩子。我不。克里德说，当然，那是德怀特。
Michael is about to split in half.
He's looking at Dwight like,
you better let him know it was my idea!
And Dwight shakes his hand.
And says, thank you, David.
And now all the power has been flipped.
Amazing, amazing writing.
They go out into the bullpen.
吉姆在给德怀特记功，他们都在看着迈克尔扭动。然后大卫说，你知道吗，德怀特？你需要和纽约的营销人员谈谈。在公司。我们想听到更多你的想法。更多你的才华。帕姆，你能安排那个电话吗？迈克尔说，我可以进去。他说，不，不，不，不，不。你有事情要做。来吧，德怀特。能在那间会议室里参加那个电话会议真是一种享受。这是我最喜欢做的事情之一。我们谈过这个。我喜欢在这些喜剧场景中做笔记。而且，你知道，很快，帕姆就不会再是接待员了。我知道。这是我最怀念的工作部分。
Wallace tells everybody.
Dwight gets this victory lap.
Pam hugs him.
I loved doing that.
I loved it.
And then Creed's like, way to go, kid.
I don't.
Creed is like, sure, it was Dwight.
能和迈克尔一起经历这些荒谬的情况。做笔记的人，因为他们在打电话，而德怀特只是在说荒谬的事情。当然，迈克尔插话了。对，因为很明显德怀特对威利·旺卡一无所知。不。然后回电，回电到一个被删减的场景，但我们喜欢那个厕所伙伴。没错。这是《招聘会》中一个被删减的场景。
Jim is giving Dwight credit and they are all watching Michael Squirm.
And then David's like, you know what, Dwight?
You need to talk to the marketing guys in New York.
in corporate. We want to hear more of your ideas. More of your brilliance. Pam, can you set up that call?
And Michael's like, I can be in there. And he's like, no, no, no, no, no. You got things to do. Come on, Dwight.
Being in that conference room for that phone call was a delight. This was one of my favorite things to do.
We've talked about this. I loved taking notes during these comedic scenes. And, you know, pretty soon, Pam isn't
going to be the receptionist anymore. I know. And this was the part of the job that I missed the most.
记得迈克尔从浴室出来，因为他口袋里的所有东西都掉进了马桶里而慌乱。是的。然后他愤怒地把手机扔进了马桶。是的。然后他说他有一个关于这个网状马桶防护罩的绝妙主意。嗯哼。现在，珍娜，在这一集里，迈克尔称它为厕所伙伴。
getting to be in these ridiculous situations with Michael.
Being the note taker because they're on the phone and Dwight is just saying ridiculous stuff.
And of course, Michael Burson.
Right, because it's really clear that Dwight doesn't know anything about Willy Wonka.
No.
Then call back, call back to a deleted scene, but that we love the toilet buddy.
That's right.
This is a deleted scene from Job Fair.
嗯哼。但在拍摄草稿中，它被称为厕所防护罩。我想在那一刻，史蒂夫称它为厕所伙伴，因为然后他作为迈克尔纠正了自己。他说，以前被称为厕所防护罩。是的。所以我认为那只是史蒂夫保持在状态中，但捕捉到了他口误了一句台词。然后德怀特提到了他的主意叫马船，我喜欢马船。
Remember Michael comes out of the bathroom, flustered because all the contents of his
pockets fell into the toilet.
Yes.
And then he threw his cell phone in the toilet out of anger.
And he says then that he had this brilliant idea about this mesh toilet guard cover.
Mm-hmm.
Now, Jenna, in the episode, Michael calls it the toilet buddy.
你可以从骑马变成只是在水上。然后迈克尔回击说厕所海绵。我不知道那是什么。它吸水性更强，厕所海绵。它吸水性更强。所以它是一个海绵做的马桶？不，我想那是给你屁股用的海绵。我不知道。上面没说。
Mm-hmm.
But in the shooting draft, it was called the toilet guard.
And I think in the moment, Steve called it toilet buddy because then he corrects himself
as Michael.
He goes, previously known as the toilet guard.
Yes.
So I think that's just Steve staying in the moment, but catching that he had flubbed a line.
And then Dwight mentions his idea called horseboat, which I love horseboat.
我们只是说……我们不确定。他说它吸水性更强。他就是这么说的。现在，女士，在这个来回中，这引出了一个我和我的朋友斯泰西在高中时发明的产品，我们当时确信这是我们成为百万富翁的门票。什么？它叫晒黑涂抹器（tan baster）。你知道那个你用来洗碗的东西，你把它装满洗洁精，末端有一个小海绵吗？
You can go from riding to just being on the water.
And then Michael hits back with toilet sponge.
I don't know what that was.
It's more absorbent, the toilet sponge.
It's more absorbent.
So it's a toilet that's a sponge?
No, I think it's a sponge for your bum.
I don't know. It doesn't say.
是的。晒黑涂抹器非常相似。安吉拉，它末端有一个小海绵，但它装满了防晒霜，你只是把它涂在自己身上，你的手保持干净。晒黑涂抹器。或者你可以买喷雾。好吧，喷雾当时还没出来，安吉拉。它还没被发明出来。你看现在我们用晒黑涂抹器无处可去，但在当时它可能是。有需求。显然喷雾已经满足了需求。但是。还有棒状的。我喜欢防晒棒。是的，安吉，我明白了。今天有很多解决方案，但我把你带回了1990年代，当时除了粘糊糊的防晒霜之外，这些东西都不存在，而我们正在
We just said...
We're not sure.
He says it's more absorbent.
That's what he says.
Now, lady, in this back and forth, this brought up a product that my friend, Stacey and I, invented in high school that we thought we were convinced was our ticket to being millionaires.
What?
It's called the tan baster.
You know that thing that you wash your dishes with that you fill up with dish soap and it has a little sponge at the end?
解决一个问题。此外，我们脑子里有整个电视广告，整个电视购物节目，因为你知道还有谁能用它吗？也许是需要涂抹乳液的老年人，因为他们有关节炎。对，或者也许他们失去了活动范围，够不到某些地方。好吧，那是晒黑涂抹器的另一个伟大之处。它就像一个抓背器。它可以伸到你的背部。看？晒黑涂抹器。我认为名字是问题的一部分。为什么？因为每次你说晒黑涂抹器，我就想到感恩节的火鸡。好吧。让我带你回去。还有沾满肉汁的皱巴巴的。让我带你回去。回到1990年代。这又是，在我们对晒伤了解那么多之前。不，不，不，不，因为你涂抹火鸡。
Yes.
The tan baster is very similar.
Angela, it has a little sponge on the end, but it's filled with sunblock and you just based it on
yourself and your hands stay clean. The tan baster. Or you could get spray. Well, spray wasn't around yet,
Angela. It hadn't been invented yet. You see now we can go nowhere with the tan baster, but at the time
it could have been. There was a need. And clearly the spray has filled the need. But. And the stick. I love me a
you know, sunscreen stick. Yeah, Ange, I get it. There's a lot of solutions today, but I'm taking
you back to the 1990s when none of these things existed except for goopy sunblock, and we were
我知道，你涂抹你的身体。如果你使用晒黑涂抹器，你会晒得很黑。你知道我在说什么吗？这是人们想要那个的时候。对。他们对防晒霜的SPF不感兴趣。对。对吧？
solving a problem. Also, we had the whole like television commercial, the whole infomercial in
our head, because you know who else could use it? Maybe older people who need to apply, you know,
lotions because they have arthritis. Right, or maybe they've lost range of motion and they can't reach some places.
Well, that was the other great thing about the tan baster. It was like a back scratcher. It could go down your back.
See? Tan baster. I think the name was part of the problem. Why? Because every time you say tan baster, I just think of a turkey on Thanksgiving.
Okay. Let me take you back. And crinkly with gravy. Let me take you back to the 1990s.
This was, again, before we kind of knew about sun damage so much.
No, no, no, no, because you based a turkey.
这是你基本上还在用碘酒给自己涂婴儿油的时候。是的。对。我不知道。我只是说。好吧。非常热情。厕所伙伴，晒黑涂抹器。
I know, and you based your body.
You're going to get nice and tan if you use the tan baster.
You know what I'm saying?
This is when people wanted that.
Right.
They weren't into sunblock for the SPF.
Right?
斯泰西，我很抱歉，我们从来没有把它搞起来。哦，好吧。斯泰西，你们在某处有一张晒黑涂抹器的草图，我很想看看。我们确实有一张晒黑涂抹器的草图。你知道我一直试图把那个晒黑涂抹器放进你和我的很多项目中。女士，我们不会有办公室女士的晒黑涂抹器。这不会发生的。好吧。
This is when you were still basically applying baby oil to yourself with iodine.
Yeah.
Right.
I don't know.
I'm just saying.
Okay.
Well, very passionate.
The toilet buddy, the tan baster.
你知道我想要什么吗，在我们做晒黑涂抹器之前，我想要桃红葡萄酒。好吧。我想我们会有更多人使用桃红葡萄酒。让我们做一个民意调查。不。你更想要什么？办公室女士的桃红葡萄酒还是办公室女士的晒黑涂抹器。我得选晒黑涂抹器。该死，我就知道你会这么说，萨姆。
Stacy, I'm sorry, we never got it off the ground.
Oh, well.
Stacey, somewhere you guys have a sketch of the tan baster, and I'd love to see it.
We do have a sketch of the tan baster.
You know I've been trying to work that tan baster into a lot of projects for you and I.
Lady, we're not going to have an office lady's tan baster.
It's just not happening.
Okay.
我就知道。你为什么认为我会这么说？不。不，因为很多喷雾和棒状产品里含有有害化学物质，比如气溶胶和对你有害的东西。卡西？我是桃红葡萄酒队的。耶！总是愿意尝试葡萄酒。
You know what I want, before we do a tan baster, I want a rosé.
Okay. I think more of us would use the rosé.
Let's put a poll out there.
No.
What do you want more?
An office lady's rosé or an office lady's tan baster.
I got to go tan baster.
Damn, I knew you were going to say it, Sam.
好吧，你知道吗？让我们在涂抹自己的同时喝桃红葡萄酒。有可能涂进我的嘴里吗？嘿！桃红葡萄酒涂抹器。也许吧。哦，我的天。我们在哪儿？
I knew it.
Why did you think I was going to say it?
No.
No, because a lot of the sprays and sticks have harmful chemicals in them, like aerosols and things that are bad for you.
Cassie?
I'm team rosé.
Yay!
Always down to try wine.
哦，伙计们，我们得去看看凯文和琳。我们得去，因为可怜的凯文这一整集都在接受很多建议。你猜怎么着？当他最终在停车场见到琳时，他做得很好。做凯文。他说，我只是要说出我心里想的一切。她有一个很棒的微笑。他想带她去吃晚饭看电影。她说好，他很高兴。然后他说胸部。她很高兴。是的。琳只是喜欢凯文。是的。就像你说的，锅配盖。确实有。德怀特给凯文的建议只是去她身边活着。这会奏效吗？最后我们有了我们的标签
Well, you know what?
Let's drink rosé while we based ourselves.
Is it possible to baste into my mouth?
Hey!
A rosé baster.
Perhaps.
Oh, my word.
Where are we?
一个最后的敲门笑话，一个叮咚笑话，真的吗？是的，我们和雷恩谈过这个，这个太搞笑了，因为德怀特认为
Oh, you guys, we got to check back in with Kevin and Lynn.
We do, because poor Kevin has been receiving a lot of advice this whole episode.
And guess what?
When he finally does meet up with Lynn in the parking lot, he does just fine.
being Kevin. He says, I'm just going to say everything I'm thinking. She has a great smile. He'd like to take her for dinner in a movie. She says yes, he's happy. And then he says boobs. And she's delighted. Yeah. Lynn just likes Kevin. Yeah. Like you said, there's a lid for every pot. There is. Dwight's advice to Kevin was just go be alive next to her.
will it work
and finally
we have our tag
他要报复吉姆，他做了叮咚，然后吉姆说，你知道吗，我刚洗完澡，我需要一秒钟，然后就像我们谈到的，他们来回说，嗯，我可以回来
a final
knock knock joke
a ding dong joke
really
yeah we talked about
this with rain
this one is so hilarious
because Dwight thinks
你什么时候方便？这太荒谬了，这就是金奖券。我们希望你喜欢。我喜欢这一集。我也喜欢。谢谢你，雷恩·威尔逊，来到我们的播客。这让我整天都感到温暖。我真的希望我们能去那边。你知道，我们有一个办公室短信群。我们谈过这个。我们是演员互相发短信，我们邀请了自己去雷恩家。所以，雷恩和对不起，霍莉，我们要来了。我们要来了。你知道，你在劳动节后的某个时候告诉我们，好吧，现在是劳动节之后了。猜猜谁记得你告诉她的日期。
he's going to get Jim back
and he does ding dong
and then Jim's like
you know what I just got out of the shower
I need one second
and then like we talked about
they go back and forth
with like well I can come back
没错。当然。我想去。好吧，伙计们，我们下周见。请查看雷恩的播客《形而上学的奶昔》，与雷扎·阿斯兰一起。我们爱你。爱你们，伙计们。祝你们过得愉快。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制片人是马特·比格尔。我们的第二杯剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛。Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。
when's good for you
it's like so ridiculous
and that is Golden T's
ticket. We hope you enjoyed. I loved this episode. I did too. And thank you, Rain Wilson, for coming on
our podcast. That just gave me all the warm fuzzies for the whole day. I really do want us to go over
there. You know, we have an office text thread. We've talked about this. We're the cast text
each other, and we have invited ourselves over to Rain. So, Rain and sorry, Holly, we're coming.
We are. You know, you told us sometime after Labor Day, well, it's after Labor Day. Guess who remembered the date you
什么时候方便？这太荒谬了，这就是Golden T的入场券。希望你们喜欢。我很喜欢这一集。我也是。谢谢雷恩·威尔森来我们的播客。这让我一整天都感到非常温暖。我真的很想让我们去那边。你知道，我们有一个办公室群聊。我们讨论过这个。我们演员之间会发短信，我们已经自作主张邀请自己去雷恩家了。所以，雷恩，抱歉了霍莉，我们要去了。我们真的要去。你知道，你告诉我们劳动节之后某个时间，嗯，现在已经是劳动节之后了。猜猜谁记得你告诉她的日期。
told her. That's right. Of course. I want to go. Well, guys, we will see you next week. Please
check out Rain's podcast Metaphysical Milkshake with Reza Aslin. We love you. Love you guys. Have a great one.
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in
collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher
and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our Second Drinks episodes are produced by
Molly Nugent. Our audio engineer is Sam Pfeiffer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah
Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is
Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
没错。当然。我想去。好吧，伙计们，我们下周见。请收听雷恩的播客《Metaphysical Milkshake with Reza Aslin》。我们爱你们。爱你们。祝你们过得愉快。感谢收听《Office Ladies》的《Second Drink》。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《Office Ladies》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的高级制作人是马特·比格尔。我们的《Second Drinks》剧集由莫莉·纽金特制作。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·菲佛。Odyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《Office Ladies》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。